mobile task force Edna 84 also known by
the code name and thus upon his Crucible
is on one of the strangest missions
they've ever been sent on they sit in a
darkened room beads of sweat trickling
down their brows the lights of computer
monitors shine upon their faces they're
tackling a monster that if it escapes
will literally devour all of creation it
has no fear it has no remorse and if it
isn't kept contained by Edna 84 it may
escape and wreak havoc across the world
oh and did we mention it's trapped in a
Minecraft server you heard us right
scp-4335 is a Cognito hazardous
extra-dimensional being of pure Terror
trapped inside a procedurally generated
world in the immensely popular game
Minecraft you hear about a lot of
horrifying monsters being described as
lovecraftian but only this monster is
Minecraft in there's a lot that needs
explaining here and we intend to get to
all of it but let's start with how the
foundation keeps This truly exceptional
Beast contained the foundation first
discovered
scp-4335 back in 2010 shortly after the
Alpha version of Minecraft was released
because of the online nature of the game
it's proven to be impossible to contain
4335 externally seeing as it isn't
confined to any one physical location
shutting off the server 4335 is found in
is not an effective containment method
either as this just causes the entity to
Simply hop to a different server the
foundation's greatest fear is that 4335
will one day make the leap out of
Minecraft and cause chaos in our world
that's why it's imperative to draft
containment procedures for
scp-4335 within the game this led to the
creation of a containment site unlike
any other site M1 the first official
Foundation site made entirely out of
Minecraft blocks everyone who was
originally involved in the server has
been removed and anistatized since then
a lead SCP Foundation containment
Specialists and Gamers have been
constructing the perfect prison for
scp-4335 side M1 is a large Stone
complex built into the side of a
mountain it has a number of key features
including a supply area filled with
materials vital for 4335's continued
containment chests filled with books
that contain
scp-4335's containment procedures a few
animal farms for the purpose of breeding
and killing livestock for their meat the
entrance to a mine several chests
containing books specifically designed
for civilians to learn about 4335 if
they ever breach containment and enter
the server and of course the actual
containment chamber for
scp-4335 itself which is a little more
complicated
4335's containment chamber is built out
of several layers all made from iron
blocks the outermost cube is 75 by 75 by
75 blocks the inner cube is 55 by 55 by
55 blocks and the innermost cube is 25
by 25 by 25 blocks creating several
levels of Defense finally one layer
within all these others which contains
the anomaly proper is made from obsidian
blocks
scp-4335 is bound into the center of the
containment chamber with a complex
mechanism the outermost cube is
completely filled with water and several
dispensers capable of rapidly dispensing
large amounts of items in a short amount
of time line the cube the cube also
contains several mob Farms which are
devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when
they die the chamber is essentially
designed to funnel a constant flow of
items inwards to
scp-4335 there are even contingency
measures for if
scp-4335 manages to breach in
containment if Escape is attempted
blocks of TNT detonate above the ceiling
causing lava to pour into the chamber at
that point MTF Edna 84 are dispatched
into the server to lure 4335 back into
its containment chamber to do this they
fire a mix of fire resistant potions and
ender pearls which have teleportation
capabilities interestingly there's one
more basic method of luring
scp-4335 back into the obsidian Cube
taunting and insulting one of
scp-4335's many anomalous abilities is
being able to hear people through the
screen and being a proud creature it
often responds to insults by charging in
to directly Engage The insulter if
scp-4335 still manages to breach the
containment that has been set up for it
then they even expect that it will
likely soon hop into another server at
that point the goal will shift to
finding the monster and re-containing it
with containment procedures this complex
and extensive it shouldn't come as a
surprise that
scp-4335 rests firmly in the ketter
class what exactly is this anomalous
entity why does its containment hinge on
constantly providing it with items and
how did it end up in Mojang's popular
building and survival game in the first
place
scp-4335 in terms of physical dimensions
appears almost identical to the player
character with an all black skin it also
appears to be constantly shrouded in a
cloud of smoke particles and has long
black tendrils protruding from its back
in some respects 4335 has been compared
to two popular Creepypasta figures
Herobrine and the Slenderman but 4335 is
far stranger its physical body behaves
similarly to most assets native to the
game with a few peculiar anomalous
abilities we'll discuss soon handling
scp-4335 is an extremely delicate
process us if command blocks creative
mode or server commands are ever enabled
in a server with
scp-4335 the server will instantly shut
down and
scp-4335 will move to a different server
scp-4335 also uses its tendrils to
destroy surrounding blocks before
consuming them with each successful
consumption
scp-4335 grows and when it reaches
sufficient size it hops to a different
server as you can see keeping
scp-4335 contained is an uphill battle
but luckily there are two factors on the
foundation side here the first is that
scp-4335 is immobilized while consuming
items and blocks limiting its ability to
actively Escape Foundation forces the
second factor is that
scp-4335 needs a rest period between
consuming blocks in order to grow
meaning if its consumption is constant
and continuous it isn't able to grow
these two factors have informed the
entirety of the foundation's containment
procedures around
scp-4335 it's locked into its chamber
and fed items and blocks constantly
effectively rooting it in place when
scp-4335 begins to grow the foundation
also found that the application of Ender
Pearls helps reduce it back to its
normal size however
scp-4335 does have a method of striking
back against its captors 4335 is a
virgin class multi-sensory Cognito
Hazard anyone viewing it without proper
training and protection may experience
distressing hallucinations
scp-4335 is also capable of telepathic
speech with people playing on its server
and as we alluded to earlier it can also
hear any noises you make while playing
weird is a term thrown around a lot when
it comes to scps considering it's pretty
much a requirement for the foundation to
take interest in you but the null
devouring Minecraft demon that can hear
you talking through your screen is
strange even by Foundation standards MTF
Edna 84 first discovered scp-4335 in the
single-player server of Minecraft user
leaking heart three team members Jason
yelsen Richard Duchamp and Shelia
Freemason covertly entered the game to
investigate and potentially apprehend
the creature when leaking Hart first
discovered their presence on what he
thought was a private server he quickly
left a little creeped out by the sudden
intrusion thankfully the trio was still
able to locate
scp-4335 they discovered the creature
hiding inside a giant crater as though
it had impacted the Earth at
considerable speed Richard Duchamp who
is the leader of the team at the time
made the mistake of looking directly at
the entity in that moment he experienced
the full force of
scp-4335's Cognito hazardous effects he
hallucinated believing that his keyboard
was melting before his eyes in the
aftermath of this incident Duchamp was
taken off the case and Jason yelson was
promoted to head of the project things
were still going to get stranger Yeltsin
was able to open a dialogue with the
creature after containing it in a
chamber filled with lava it asked him
whether it had landed in the right
location meaning our world and yelson
informed him that it somehow fallen into
the world of Minecraft instead the
creature was at first confused and then
angry and resentful about its situation
it vowed to find its way into our world
somehow and obtain more sustenance a few
months after this The Entity managed to
breach containment and hop into another
server Yeltsin and two others once again
managed to track it down and recontain
it but this time two civilians also
inhabiting the server were exposed to
the anomalous effects of
scp-4335 they weren't heard but they did
appear strange and incoherent after
experiencing 4335's Cognito hazards the
foundation tracked them down in the
aftermath and gave them amnestic
treatment
4335 was contained shortly thereafter
once again Yeltsin came face to face
with his new phone eight months after
being captured 4335 granted Yeltsin
another interview from containment 4335
admitted that it almost respected
Yeltsin and the rest of the foundation
for figuring out how to capture and
contain it so quickly in exchange it
would give the foundation something
extremely valuable information first it
asked one question of yelson how does he
Define creation yosin replied uh
something that is built and brought into
this universe by a Sapient being using
other things from this universe 4335
agreed it went on to explain that it
came from a universe devoid of creation
a dark and unknowable place filled with
nothing but violent random chaos its
Dimension existed directly above ours
and it often looked down at us through a
dimensional window fascinated by all the
creation below it plotted and dreamed to
one day infiltrate our reality and yes
and finally had the opportunity to ask
the magic question why though he wasn't
quite ready for the brutal honesty of
scp-4335's reply I do not like to lie so
I will tell you now I wish to suck it
dry of the toys of whatever Force
controls your Universe destroy the light
destroy the Earth and Destroy Humanity
it reminded me of me a blubbering mass
of intelligence and order it sickens me
in ways I cannot comprehend I hope you
understand
scp-4335 was a connoisseur of creation
and it sought to devour all of it in
this moment Yeltsin realized what an
incredibly dangerous entity he was
dealing with the only mystery was why
this creature had somehow landed in
Minecraft instead of our
which appeared to be the only thing that
saved us but yelson didn't have time to
think 4335 was about to Stage another
daring escape attempt one of its
tendrils reached out and attacked
yelson's player character in that moment
the real-life yelson began to
hallucinate and panic suddenly back in
the game a series of abnormally tall
slender black figures appeared and began
deconstructing the containment chamber
around
scp-4335 it had somehow summoned new
minions into the game to assist in this
Containment Breach Jason yelson entered
Cognito Hazard quarantine following this
incident and was removed from the
project and he wasn't the only one
affected by this incident following the
first appearance of these long dark
figures players across the globe began
to experience them appearing in their
own games the foundation managed to find
a solution they contacted Mojang and had
the creatures patched into the game
during the next update as a new
non-anomalous entity which seemed to
stop 4335 from being able to use them as
its own tools they're now known as the
Enderman and are beloved among fans for
being one of the creepier enemies to
this day containment efforts continue
for
scp-4335 but there's only one question
left why did The Entity fall into
Minecraft rather than our world the file
posits the most likely answer because
4335 defines creation as elements made
by Sapient beings in Minecraft the most
popular game in the world at the height
of 4335's power everything that exists
is the product of code made by humans
creation is truly abundant there as for
our world in
scp-4335's extra dimensional eyes there
is no Nation no intelligent design no
soothing piano soundtrack just
frightening chaotic Randomness which is
too unlike its own Dimension so even if
scp-4335 ever did arrive in our reality
we would likely be disappointed by how
little there is to eat you're sitting in
the middle of a cheering crowd the arena
around you is electric fans hollering
from their seats as they watch the
basketball game every Point scored every
shot missed and every skillful pass of
the ball sends waves of excitement over
everyone in the audience Applause shouts
and chants fill the air it distracts you
for a moment you find yourself swept up
in the energy of the game but slowly
surely a nagging feeling creeps up on
you as your eyes follow the ball that
feeling turns to a sickening realization
as one of the players jumps and dunks
the basketball scoring another two
points you notice the look on his face
the same look on the faces of all the
other players on the court a solemn
hopeless expression it's the same look
of Silent despair worn by all the
spectators around you then you remember
you've watched this exact game of
basketball before many many times before
and that is when you feel the same
hopeless expression appear on your own
face realizing just how long you have
been here watching this game over and
over reminded that you will never ever
leave this Arena welcome to
scp-1733 to the untrained eye
scp-1733 seems to be a completely
harmless item stored in a digital video
recorder it is kept securely in the
dusty depths of the SCP foundation's
video archives if any researcher is
given permission to study scp-1733 they
will find it to be an ordinary VHS tape
but what about the contents of said tape
does it contain a bizarre disconnected
series of black and white video clips
that when viewed only give the Watchers
seven days before the spirit of a
drowned girl comes crawling out of their
TV screen to kill them well not exactly
but we're sure that if such a tape
exists the foundation probably has it
under lock and key too the footage on
scp-1733 is a seemingly banal as the
ordinary VHS tape itself when played the
viewer will witness a TV broadcast of a
basketball game specifically the
2010-2011 NBA season opener broadcast on
television and captured on tape by an
unknown civilian the game took place on
the 26th of October 2010 in the TD
Garden arena in Boston Massachusetts a
game where the hometown Boston Celtics
took on the Miami Heat by now perhaps
you're wondering what is so special
about this particular game and why the
SCP Foundation would be so interested in
keeping a VHS recording of it so secure
is one of the o5 councils secretly a
Celtics fan well that's impossible to
say for sure what we do know for certain
is that scp-1733 is far more than just a
harmless recording of a basketball game
the SCP Foundation First caught wind of
scp-1733's existence the day after the
game on October 27th a Boston native
that had watched and recorded the game
made comments on social media about a
technical foul that the game's referee
had failed to pick up on according to
this individual during the third quarter
an instance of unsportsmanlike conduct
took place between Ray Allen and Chris
Bosh the person making these claims was
quickly ridiculed by commenters on the
same thread but then this person
uploaded a clip of this foul from the
footage they had recorded the other
commenters were dumbfounded during the
original broadcast that foul had never
happened but the recording showed it
clear as day the footage was quick
expunged and all traces of the clip
removed from the Internet by Personnel
acting on behalf of the SCP Foundation
any that had viewed the video on
Facebook or been a part of the comments
debating this previously non-existent
foul were Tracked Down via their IP
addresses all of them including the
owner of the tape were given amnestics
to wipe their memories of the supposed
infraction an scp-1733 was returned to
the foundation for further analysis
researchers at the foundation were
determined to understand the anomalous
nature of
scp-1733 and why the footage contained
on this particular VHS tape was so
different from the basketball game's
original broadcast at first the
differences in the game seem to be only
slight changes from the one that
actually aired on TV a different foul
here a small Point difference there
while the recording of the game
contained on scp-1733 was slightly
different from the real-life game
perhaps even more in interesting was
that these differences changed with
repeat viewings researchers wouldn't
observe the same differences every time
they watched scp-1733 but would instead
spot something different that had been
changed each time they restarted the
tape and as they continued to watch and
re-watch
scp-1733's footage the true horror of
the video's anomalous properties became
more and more apparent as the footage
recorded on scp-1733 began to diverge
more and more from the original
broadcast researchers shifted their
attention away from the basketball game
itself and on to the people watching it
just like the specifics of the game
itself the fans in the arena seem to
also change with every re-watch of the
tape and even stranger the people in the
crowd seem to not only be aware of their
existence within the footage but also
retained memories of every previous
replayed Vision each time the
researchers had watched scp-1733 the
audience trapped within had gained more
and more cognizance every man woman and
child in the audience of that basketball
game began remembering that they had
seen multiple variations of the same
game over and over again this first
became apparent to Foundation
researchers when the game's commentators
to presenters named Mike and Tommy began
to comment on a strange sense of deja vu
they were experiencing as they watched
the Boston Celtics and Miami Heat play
both seemed to share Notions that the
game they were witnessing was strangely
familiar and in later replays of the
tape these two commentator personalities
were able to recall the events of the
game with perfect Vivid accuracy while
they never addressed the viewer directly
this cumulative effect seems to have
extended to every person that was
present within the arena at the time
that the original broadcast was recorded
everyone from the commentators to the
coaches the players to the patrons all
remember the diverging versions of the
basketball game but seem to have no
awareness that they are trapped inside a
recording on a VHS tape it should be
noted that it is still unclear whether
the entities are real people or digital
copies that solely reside on the tape
every individual shown to be inside TD
Garden on the 26th of October 2010 seems
to be identical to their counterparts in
the real world each of the basketball
players on both the Boston Celtics and
Miami Heat teams have the exact same
level of talent as they do in reality
and their individual mannerisms are
perfectly recreated in the scp-1733
footage and the same is true of the fans
in the audience each one appearing to be
in every conceivable way a living human
being but the most unnerving aspect of
scp-1733 was found when the foundation
agents were tasked with tracking down
members of the audience who were seen on
the tape and they found nothing unlike
the players and coaches who can quite
easily be found in our world with many
of them still playing or involved with
professional basketball Personnel were
unable to find a single trace of any of
the people from the audience not one
clue as to their current whereabouts or
status it is unclear how but it appears
that everyone shown on
scp-1733 especially those watching the
game unfold from the stands is a person
trapped in digital form stuck watching
variations of the same match on Loop
researchers at the SCP Foundation who
were studying as CP 1733 initially
theorized that the tape had been
designed to display an infinite variety
of different game outcomes given that
the tactics utilized by the players were
different with each playback of scp-1733
this seemed to be the case that the tape
was showing a what if scenario each time
the tape was rewound and played from the
start but the scenario wasn't resetting
each time it was clear that they were
learning by the 30 fourth replay of the
footage the Boston Celtics and Miami
Heat were so in tune with the opposing
team's Playbook that both sides players
were able to perfectly and precisely
counter their opponent's moves and kept
the score at 0-0 for much of the game at
this stage in the foundation's research
the players on the scp-1733 tape had not
yet become fully aware that they had
played the same game already in earlier
playbacks but it is possible that weak
memories of the earlier versions of the
same match manifested as instinctive
ways players could counter the moves of
their rival team however by the time
Foundation researchers had replayed the
scp-1733 footage 45 times the players
their coaches and fans watching the game
had become aware of what was happening
to them it was at this point that the
digital recording from TD Garden changed
dramatically realizing that they'd been
playing the same game of basketball over
and over the players refused to
participate any longer everyone in the
audience began to attempt to escape from
the tape where they'd been unknowingly
imprisoned but not a single one of the
stadium stores would budge and neither
the fans nor the players seemed to be
able to leave through any other exit out
of TD Garden over the following
playbacks of the scp-1733 videotape
attempts at Escape grew increasingly
daring in one playback a full-scale riot
broke out in another makeshift
explosives were built and used by those
trapped to try and blast their way to
Freedom as their cognition grew when
they began to remember friends and
family from outside the videotape the
crowd trapped an scp-1733 grew even more
desperate players and their coaches
retired to locker rooms withdrawing from
the crowd for a Time the rest of the
people in the footage began to form
factions amongst themselves one of the
more prominent calling themselves the
faith Keepers these individuals voiced
their belief that they had been confined
to TD Garden as some form of spiritual
punishment as a result of the
consumerism that is Rife in a
post-industrial society the faith
Keepers began burning offerings in the
center of the basketball court phones
wallets car keys anything that reminded
them of the modern world over the
subsequent playbacks of scp-1733 the
faith Keepers grew in their numbers
indoctrinating more of the crowd into
their movement those still trying to
escape from the stadium were causing
more damage to themselves than their
enclosure with three men caught in the
blast of another crude bomb placed on an
exit door unfortunately for them the
door barely showed a scratch in the
aftermath of the detonation as
Foundation researchers continued
replaying the tape those trapped with an
scp-1733 descended into depraved acts
and incidences of violence became
rampant some even attempted to take
their own lives and acts of desperation
jumping from balconies in the hopes of
ending the loop those that had joined
the growing ranks of the faith Keepers
did not engage in such Behavior instead
creating makeshift curtains to separate
themselves from the breakdown that was
taking place among the others trapped
within the
scp-1733 tank at some point beyond the
112th playback of the videotape the
faith Keepers marched off screen and
brought the basketball teams back out
onto the main Court they then began a
ritualistic sacrifice disemboweling the
professional athletes for their fellow
prisoners to see this had no noticeable
effect with the recording of the game
resetting as it had done in earlier
re-watches in a later playback the faith
Keepers then began to call for all the
children in the stadium to be sacrificed
in the same way testing on scp-1733 was
finally suspended indefinitely after
this point and as far as we know the
crowd remains trapped inside the
anomalous recording of this particular
Celtics Heat basketball game Foundation
researchers have been unable to produce
the same anomalous effects as those of
scp-1733 even when using the DVR that
originally produced the recording the
digital video recorder itself does not
seem to imprint the same properties onto
other VHS tapes making
scp-1733 and isolated anomaly however
the next time you find yourself in a
basketball game it might be worth asking
yourself have I seen this game before
have you ever had a nightmare that
you're running down a long dark hallway
getting chased by something you can't
see the thing behind you isn't fast but
that doesn't matter you can't run
forever and the thing knows it it is a
patient Predator it toys with its food
at first you move with speed and Rhythm
the metallic scraping noise behind you
grows quieter you run and stumble
through the dark your muscles start to
ache and your lungs burn your pace slows
it's still coming you can hear the
scraping getting louder you start to
it's completely dark you don't know
where you're running or even what you're
running from all you know as you bump
against the walls and the sharp Corners
that Rush towards you is that you can't
run forever you trip fall and pain
explodes through your legs as your knee
shatters on the concrete ground that
scraping is getting louder you can
barely breathe you can't run anymore
with your injury there's no way to stop
what's coming there is no escape the
scraping is right behind you you scream
and then you wake up your heart is
pounding like thunder in your chest and
your sheets are soaked with sweat but
you're safe you're out of those awful
dark hallways but what if this wasn't
just a nightmare what if this scenario
was real and there was no escape from
the horror chasing you in the darkness
that's what it's like to have a close
encounter with
scp-1918 a sadistic sentient object that
loves playing Twisted games with its
prey but this monster never plays fair
and even worse it's always just a simple
door away it may even be hiding behind a
door near you right now waiting to start
start a game with its new playmate but
soon you'll understand why some doors
should never ever be opened and why some
games are better left unplayed
scp-1918 is an anomaly with two parts
scp-1918 itself and
scp-1918-2 the monster's underground
lair the duo are a match made in hell as
the chambers and hallways of 1918-2 are
perfectly tailored to 1918's Violent
Hobbies nobody knows how long this
anomaly has been operating but it's
probably behind countless disappearances
after all 1918 has a habit of breaking
its toys the nightmare began in a small
town in Maine with a population of only
226 people but that population was about
to get lower people in the town began to
report strange noises at night a droning
metal on concrete scraping noise like
someone dragging a lead pipe along the
ground at first people just ignored the
sound it was all in their heads or maybe
just a faulty oven or a washing machine
on the fritz anything that would allow
them to forget about the noise and get
on with their daily lives but the noises
were coming from below they could be
heard out on the streets most audibly
near manholes and Sewer grates people
started feeling unsafe in their homes
the noises were spooking animals and
children people were losing sleep that's
scraping they all tried to ignore was
beginning to get to them all letters
emails and angry phone calls to the Town
Council were piling up something had to
be done before the whole town went crazy
with fear the mayor authorized four
utility workers to investigate the
source of the noise at a local sewage
treatment facility considering the
scraping was loudest near the sewer
grates everyone just assumed that
whatever was causing all this must be
connected to the sewers four utility
workers were sent to investigate the the
facility only to find that the Machinery
on site was working just fine the source
of the problems must have been coming
directly from the underground sewer
lines themselves the four workers
equipped with headlamps descended into a
long service tunnel that fed into the
sewer system as they pass deeper into
the tunnel the darkness around them
became thicker it was a tangible
presence that drowned out the light of
their headlamps similar to the anomalous
phenomenon exhibited by
scp-087 when the utility workers tried
to turn back they discovered another
impossibility it seemed that the tunnel
behind them had become a solid concrete
wall they were trapped but where it was
too dark to tell confused and terrified
the four men stuck together attempting
to find a way out it was too dark to see
their hand in front of their face so all
they could do was navigate Slowly by
feeling the walls around them these
walls felt old crusty there was a kind
of metallic stench hanging in the air
too like old blood something horrible
had happened here and something horrible
was about to happen again all they could
do was keep moving and try to stay calm
eventually after hours of pawing at the
walls in the dark they found an open
doorway one by one they filed inside
only to feel blinded when bright white
ceiling lights suddenly switched on the
room was all white and filled with pipes
large and small running from wall to
wall just then one of the utility
workers let out an ear splitting scream
and pointed towards the doorway his
colleagues turned and gasped in shock
there was something outside the door and
it was staring at them the object filled
up almost the entire doorway it seemed
like a demonic hobby horse made from a
black and white candy striped metal pole
with a crude plastic head on top the
head looked like a clowns with a wide
toothy grin but no visible herbal eyes
it was
scp-1918. the utility workers were
frozen as the object leaned forward
slightly and slithered into the room the
bottom of the metal pipes scraping
against the ground it was the exact same
scraping noise that had been haunting
the concerned townsfolk up above this
was the thing behind it all and as the
object moved its metal poles started to
scrape words into the ground tick tack
toe none of the four utility workers
were ever seen again it didn't take long
for the SCP Foundation to descend upon
this quiet main town and pick up the
pieces all relevant officials were
provided them knee sticks and cover
stories were created for the
disappearances of the four utility
workers the foundation also commandeered
the sewage treatment facility that held
the entrance to
scp-1918-2 replacing all key roles at
the facility with undercover Foundation
Personnel
scp-1918 was given a Euclid
classification due to the fixed nature
of its hunting grounds and then the real
research began the foundation soon made
some disturbing discoveries entrances
into the
scp-1918-2 area didn't follow any kind
of logic the hunting ground of scp-1918
can be entered from almost any location
if you're unlucky enough there are
currently nine known entrances including
five sewage grates three utility shafts
located in a sewage facility and one
toilet and these are just the ones that
the foundation knows about there are a
huge number of ways to enter
scp-1918-2 but to this day nothing has
ever been able to leave
scp-1918-2 is contained 20 meters below
the streets of this unassuming main Town
Personnel aside from Foundation approved
d-class guinea pigs a refused entrance
researchers have mapped out the layout
of 1918-2 through seismic Imaging of
scp-1918's movements there are 18
identical room pairs in
scp-1918-2 or nine compound rooms rooms
are differentiated between a one room
and a two room by crude carvings on the
floors outside of the individual rooms
scp-1918-2 is symmetrical with half a
meter wide path circling each compound
room the only deviation to this
construction are the location of
entrances on the sides of each
individual room which very randomly
while the location is active what
exactly does scp-1918 do in this private
little maze it plays games of course its
two favorites as indicated by the words
it scrapes into the ground Arctic tac
toe and memory in tic-tac-toe 1918 moves
to each one room leaving behind X
markings on the floors if the room is
not already marked with an o in a manner
similar to a game of tic-tac-toe how a
victim is meant to accomplish making a
Mark or understanding this process
process is unknown as no AIDS are given
blood is commonly used by victims to
make their markings hence the rusty
smell in many of the rooms in memory the
trapped victim is rendered unconscious
by blunt force presumably from scp-1918
the subject regains Consciousness in a
random section of the facility success
is marked by finding a one room
identical to the central room this event
seems to possess a time limit as the
subject is pursued by scp-1918 through
the halls of the facility the subject
wins by marking the correct room with an
O what happens if you win or lose these
games it's important to note that
scp-1918 is very competitive and doesn't
play fair if you win the object will
merely accuse you of cheating and start
a new game this will happen again and
again until eventually you lose and what
do you do well take the horrifying
encounter d-class personnel number d2934
had with
scp-1918 wearing video and audio
equipment d-2934 was led into
scp-1918-2 by Foundation researchers
when he eventually found his way to the
central room 1918 challenged him to a
game of Tic-tac-toe and Against All Odds
d-2934 won the game but 1918 didn't take
kindly to that it accused d-2934 of
cheating carving its accusations into
the ground before challenging him to a
deadly game of memory after hours of
chasing d-2934 eventually lost his mind
and was backed into a corner by 1918. as
the object made its way towards him he
panicked ripped a pipe from the wall and
began smashing 1918's head as the
plastic cracked under the force of the
blows Foundation scientists could see
real brains inside
d2934 screamed and the video feed cut
off when the video turned back on
sometime time later 1918 stared into the
camera with a different head mounted
atop its metal pole one that just a few
hours earlier had belonged to the
unfortunate
d2934 if there's one lesson to be
learned from this terrifying anomaly
it's that there truly Is No Escape From
scp-1918.
God damn it the comment section on this
one is gonna be hell do your worst you
filthy animals
now before we begin today's video let's
clear some things up we know exactly
what you're thinking and Among Us SCP
this sounds ridiculous why would the
foundation ever have to deal with an
anomaly relating to Among Us of all
things is this some kind of sick joke
dreamed up by our YouTube commenters and
look we get it it's definitely one of
the more ridiculous anomalies the
foundation has had to contain at least
at face value but there are a few things
you should take into consideration
before things get to Among Us pilled
around here oh God first this is hardly
the strangest anomaly we've covered on
SCP explained
scp-5981 also known as nuke City
revolved around a mysterious broadcast
of a Family Guy episode
scp-4335 a welcome The Crucible had to
deal with an entity occupying space
inside the video game Minecraft but
there are countless other examples of
anomalies creeping into popular culture
mutating it and twisting it for their
own purposes what may seem silly on
paper such as the foundation having to
do research on a popular video game like
Among Us is all part of what the
organization does if the brave
researchers at the SCP Foundation
chuckled and brushed off a Potential
Threat just because it had to do with
something like Among Us the entire
population might be susceptible to a
supernatural event of unprecedented
proportions the foundation's entire veil
of secrecy could crumble all because
someone Shrugged off the possibility of
allocating resources to deal with the
threat millions of civilians could
discover these games movies and shows
are all immensely popular and an anomaly
affecting a global phenomenon like among
us could spell Doom for not only the
foundation but the entire world as well
if left unchecked so if you don't want
to risk termination please try to keep a
straight face as we divulge into the
weird and wacky story free of
scp-5167 an anomaly co-named in the
foundations database has
when the Imposter is sus oh God I hate
my job sometimes to begin we need to go
back way way back centuries before Among
Us was even conceived as a concept
before video games had been invented and
even before electricity itself was
discovered back to an Era where the gods
of Olympus ruled Supreme and stone
marble statues line buildings that would
serve as Timeless Feats of architecture
and where a new school of thought was
developing one that focused on logic and
reason instead of superstition and
hearsay that's right we're talking about
ancient Greece a society that for all of
its achievements and progression in the
fields of Education cultures and logic
was still largely governed by religion
and mythology but of course as you may
come to Expect When dealing with the SCP
Foundation there's always a little truth
in that which we cannot understand while
those who are on unaware of the
Paranormal might derive the Greeks for
being overly focused on a Pantheon of
gods they logically should have no
reason to believe those who know that
anything can happen in the world of the
anomalous may approach this topic and
the subject of religion in general In a
Different Light the Greek gods were very
real while the myths may not be entirely
true and they may not have been literal
Gods there were a group of anomalous
entities who influence Greek society
performing miraculous Feats that left
those who observed them in complete
wonder and putting together Cults of
worship surrounding them while most of
this was done in secret word of these
beings traveled incredibly fast in the
ancient world and they were heralded as
Gods beings of divine might that could
do anything in the universe who existed
above the Mortal plain and demanded
worship from their followers a glance at
Greek mythology paints a picture of a
group of gods who acted more or less
like he humans they fought they killed
they argued and they felt human emotions
it's likely that this characterization
and the stories emerge from how these
entities conducted themselves in
actuality there were dozens upon dozens
of entities the Greeks worshiped as
Divinity and while the stories portrayed
the gods as jealous vengeful beings who
constantly fought with each other it
doesn't compare to the reality of the
situation which was much more Cutthroat
you see there were 12 gods of Olympus
and you probably know most of them
they're remembered today for a reason
Zeus Athena Poseidon Ares the list goes
on we still remember these beings
because of the iconic stories they took
part in and how significant they were in
ancient times while for every Zeus god
of lightning there were five more Gods
who absolutely no one but the most
hardcore historical fanatic remember
gods of Niche subjects what small
followings who never had those character
defining myths to flesh them out and
preserve them for all of history to
remember who would when Greece foul Fade
Into Obscurity for every Zeus there was
a pythonius who was pythonius you ask
well if the guy heard you asking that
question he'd probably Smite you down
before the question even left your lips
if he wasn't engaged in a hardcore game
of Among Us that
don't worry we'll get there all will be
explained it's the name of the channel
after all fathonius was a god of
jealousy and envy mainly in a romantic
context do you have a crush on someone
who's already takenthonius knows all
about that do you wish you weren't
trapped in a dead-end relationship with
someone who doesn't love you thonius
understands your plight but thonius
wasn't just a reverse Bizarro Cupid he
was a literal personification of the
emotions of jealousy and envy themselves
no matter the context if it was petty
and greedy phonius knew it all too well
you would think that this would make
thonius a prime candidate for some
mythological drama right after all the
Greek gods loved their infighting and
who better to stir up some Hera said
Zeus said arguments than a literal God
of Envy well it didn't quite work out
that way for thonius his appearances and
myths were infrequent and today he is
nearly all but forgotten reduced to a
mere three sentences on a Wikipedia page
while other figures from his era have
taken on an entirely new life in the
modern day as cultural icons like
Perseus or Hercules but no poor thonius
whose penchant for jealousy and envy
backfired on him and catapulted him Into
Obscurity why did this happen it's kind
of obvious when you think about it while
other gods granted their worshipers a
good harvest or copious amounts of wine
and partying all phonies had to offer
was well the ugly side of humanity his
worshipers were far and few between
after all no one wanted their entire
life to revolve around the jealousy of
others and thonius being a
personification of Envy had an
understandably difficult time getting
people to devote themselves to him
thonius was greedy and envied the other
gods so while he would accept nothing
but absolute worship from his followers
he couldn't offer much else especially
not when compared to the Bountiful Boons
lay a great God like Zeus or Hera could
offer and so phony is festered an ugly
God who wallowed in self-hatred and
irrelevancy constantly living in the
shadow of the pantheon that gave him
purpose and his purpose was to remain
jealous to remain envious of those who
had what he did not a god unfit to be
worshiped whose purpose was to embody
the feelings of wanting what isn't yours
phonius is both tragic and poetic and
when the Greeks faded away so too did
sonius the Roman Empire who largely
adapted Greece's Pantheon of gods for
their own stories left no record of
bringing phonius into the mix for
centuries he was a god without a home
attempting to find a place in a changing
world phonius was angry jealous envious
and tired the forces of the universe
would call him forth in every new era
thrusting him back into the world and
forcing him to search for the sustenance
beings that were referred to as Gods fed
off of devotion but every time phonius
would find himself walking the earth
once again he would instead discover
that there was no place for him mankind
was moving on there was less and less
room for Gods with every passing Year
all the popular ones had established
themselves as Everlasting religious
figures at this point and they would
never fade away some took pleasure in
living among humans rising to power as
people of influence and fame others who
could not find a place in the world
would Fade Away Never to be revived or
worshiped ever again Forgotten Dead Gods
who the world long outgrew butthonius's
jealous Spirit would never allow him to
consign himself to that fate he hated
who he was and what he stood for but
that nature brought him back so many
times before it was his jealousy of the
other gods who were somehow managing to
linger beyond their Greek Heyday that
caused him to persevere he needed a
purpose one last chance to be remembered
he had struggled for centuries and this
was his last-ditch effort to be
remembered wherever he would wake up in
the modern era phonius would have to
make the most out of it and this is
where Among Us comes in in late 2020 the
SCP Foundation was just as captivated as
anyone else by the Among Us phenomenon a
game that was sweeping the globe where
players took on the roles of crewmates
on a spaceship one of which was an
imposter whose job was to secretly
murder the other players while they were
busy doing tasks that range from
scanning themselves in the med Bay or
scanning key cards in the admin room The
Imposter would be lurking behind every
corner sometimes in the ship's air vents
waiting for the proper moment to strike
if a dead body was found a player could
report it and the players would then
discuss which one of them they suspected
to be the Imposter the game's addictive
psychological elements and accessible
rules made it a Smash Hit but for the
foundation they were infatuated with it
for entirely different reasons you see
when a piece of media attains the level
of Fame that Among Us did the foundation
has to make sure to keep their eyes on
it popular media is a prime target for
anomalies the population's collective
attention on it just seems to invite the
forces of the supernatural world to warp
and distort what we know to be familiar
and this is exactly what was was
happening to Among Us for months the
foundation was documenting cases of an
entity who appeared in games of Among Us
and caused havoc in the real world these
cases and their after effects were so
severe that the foundation deemed the
anomaly significant enough to get its
own file in the database designating it
under the name as CP
scp-5167 would join games of Among Us
like any other player they would blend
in much like the Imposter in the game
and play just as anyone else would it
was what happened after a player
participated in a session with
scp-5167 that had the foundation
investigating every aspect of the game
those who played with
scp-5167 would find themselves stricken
by a severe case of paranoia and
capgrass delusion a psychological
condition in which a victim would come
to believe those around them had been
replaced with identical imposters the
severity of this disorder vary between
individuals but some believed the
delusions to such an extent that they
lashed out at those they believed to be
imposters sometimes resulting in a
homicide naturally the foundation put
two and two together which led back to
Among Us after several months of police
cases relating to completely average
individuals suddenly striking out at
their loved ones sometimes killing them
and showing signs of capgrass delusion
the organization knew that something was
happening on an anomalous scale at first
it was difficult to make the connection
to among us but the foundation
eventually learned from interviews with
victims and an examination of their
habits over the past few weeks they had
all played the game and through analysis
of the Among Us communities various
Trends and habits the foundation
discovered
scp-5167 an entity that was slowly
gaining notoriety within the game's
Community as an almost mythological
figure
scp-5167's tendency to spout long word
he rants at other players during the
game's emergency meeting sessions
position them as an inside joke for
those who encountered them needing to
establish a link between these
anomalously induced bouts of paranoia
the foundation set up a group of web
crawler AIS to track Among Us game
sessions until
scp-5167 would appear it was a long shot
but it was one of the many different
theories on why these victims were
undergoing this level of psychosis and
if it proved to be true then the
foundation would have a solid idea of
what to do next after weeks of nothing
scp-5167 was spotted in a game and the
foundation acted quickly to track down
the other players who played alongside
the entity naturally they exhibited
signs of paranoia and delusion some of
them only for weeks and others for
months that was enough evidence for the
foundation would later document several
other occurrences of games with
scp-5167 resulting in these psyche
conditions in other players the
foundation did what they do best and
established a series of special
containment procedures that would wipe
scp-5167 from the internet as best they
could web crawlers were trained to take
down any mentions of the entity and if a
potential sighting was discovered the
foundation would investigate any and all
players involved in the incident anyone
affected by
scp-5167 would be held under the guise
of receding medical treatment for mental
health issues and they would be
amnesticized completely you might be
thinking that the after effects of
scp-5167 are relatively tame compared to
what the foundation usually deals with
but look at it this way Among Us is a
game played by millions of people if
scp-5167 affected only a fraction of
that population it would spell total
chaos for the foundation not only that
but the amount of Bloodshed The Entity
would cause would be nothing to scoff at
as a large amount of cases dealt with
victims outright murdering anyone they
suspected to be an imposter attempting
to track down the
scp-5167 entity were met with failure
All Points of internet access that the
foundation was able to get their hands
on only led to a series of abandoned
home addresses in rural Greece but over
time things started to change the
foundation began to place less of a
concern on
scp-5167 it was almost as if the entity
was being forgotten why this letter
addressed to the
scp-5167 research team from the site's
director might clear some things up as
requested by had researcher Abrams I've
had the site-22 analyst look into the
progress of
scp-5167's anomalous effects over the
period we've observed it and the results
are much as I expected when we first
discovered
scp-5167 for the sake of argument let's
say this is when
scp-5167 first came into existence the
impact it had on its victims was severe
I don't think I have to remind you of
what Billy Heath did to his family's
faces but since then almost immediately
really since that first couple of
manifestations the potency of its
effects have started to decline full
Detachment from reality became delusion
and delusion has now become paranoia and
the intensity of that paranoia is
lessening in each new case this is all
conjecture of course and shouldn't be
taken as gospel but based on what we've
observed of this anomaly thus far our
estimation is that
scp-5167's anomalous effects will become
inert by the end of the year whether
it'll keep popping up in these video
game matches is another story though it
was just as the Director had explained
scp-5167's cases were becoming less
severe they were almost becoming
irrelevant so much so that the
foundation hypothesized that the
anomalies declining potency would lead
to its neutralization before long an
entity Fading Into irrelevance and
obscurity once more if you haven't
figured out yet maybe
scp-5167's username will spell it out
for you when the entity joined games of
Among Us it made sure that everyone knew
who it was while everyone would know who
it was if the entity had managed to
maintain any form of popularity over the
past dozen centuries or so that's right
scp-5167 would join under the name
sonius the God's New Life had thrusted
into the modern day except this time it
was inside the game of Among Us where it
was forced to cope with the reality that
the world seemed to be more obsessed
with a trendy game than any God or
mythological figure while inside the
game thonius was one bitter individual
during emergency meetings instead of
trying to figure out if red was suss or
not the God would just yell the players
around him one player asked thonius what
they were doing while the rest of the
crew was performing their tasks to which
thonius poetically responded where was I
I was there when the mountains were
newborn and the ocean's virginal I was
there when Gods walked among men and
their wisdom was cast down like sunlight
I was there when mankind was capable of
Legends and now I find myself in a world
that has forgotten even the taste of
life even the very concept of Life
Beyond existing from one day to the next
mere continuance where all the world is
wasted away in idle play of emotion that
once rang true I am in the world where
even the gods are forgotten their bones
washed away by time a world where man
has moved on where all the Legacy I have
left are three sentences on Wikipedia I
thought my time had come again I thought
this could be the new me but this is
nothing let me stay dead this time I'm
tired to which the other players
responded in typical Among Us fashion
that phonius was sus he was promptly
voted as the Imposter and ejected from
the airlock and so the tragic tale of
thonius came to a close a tired obscure
God who never had a place in the world
his presence and Among Us grew less and
less as the game's popularity waned and
once again he would Fade Into Obscurity
but the nature of thonius meant that he
would in some form return again one day
where or how no one could say but as
long as there was a situation to reap
Envy from a trend to be jealous of
thonius would remain
eternally doomed to suffer the fate of
being nobody's favorite God and frankly
we can't imagine this video will change
that for many Avid video game fans those
who just can't get enough of grinding
away for hours on quests battling
endless enemies and exploring infinite
Virtual Worlds Landing a job as a
gameplay tester seems like the perfect
opportunity doing your favorite thing in
the world and getting paid to do it well
that's the dream plus the added benefit
of seeing how the sausage gets made of
getting access to a game still in
development and suggesting ways it can
be improved think of all the gaming
disasters that might have been avoided
with a few more play testers in the room
looking at you Fallout New Vegas and
your NPCs with the spinning heads well
One Gamer had the same thought a young
man by the name of Danny wheeler when he
spotted an ad seeking beta play testers
for an in-development RPG from an
up-and-coming indie game Studio he
jumped at the chance to apply the pay
wasn't amazing but it was definitely a
better gig than his current job at the
local convenience store Hawking energy
drinks to snarky teens and counting down
the hours until he could get back home
kick up his feet and get away from it
all with a controller in his hand but
sometimes things that seem too good to
be true actually are at first Danny had
a perfectly enjoyable time testing the
game it was standard RPG fantasy fodder
and though he made sure to inform the
developer that he found the steampunk
aesthetic to be a little bit played out
at this point there was nothing at all
notable about it it was fine but the
development team kept going on and on
about the Tactical heuristic algorithms
and how the game was meant to learn the
more the player played so Dany was
instructed to log as many hours of this
exceedingly average game as possible he
sat at his desk for hours sipping on an
extra large soda and clicking away
fighting Orcs goblins and more slowly
the difficulty began to increase and the
game started to grow on him a bit he
even developed a favorite character to
play as the Rogue with his stealth and
proficiency for close range combat the
more he played as the Rogue however the
more he started to notice the game's
characters behaving differently enemies
were attacking him with ranged weapons
from far away they were setting traps to
ruin his character's stealthy approach
and catch him in the ACT then the game
started to glitch a lot to the point of
becoming nearly unplayable enemies would
fall to the ground as if Dead when he
hadn't dealt them a single blow as he
started to walk his characters away from
them they would suddenly spring back to
life and strike before he could even
think about a defense if he did
he did he could swear the game's
characters were deliberately trying to
trick him it only got more frustrating
from there with enemies making sudden
loud sounds to catch him off guard and
startle him out of concentration and
other characters staring down the barrel
of the camera with serious unblinking
eyes as if they could see him through
his monitor one day he fired up the game
to see that its characters somehow had
rearranged various torches to spell out
you'll never amount to anything Dany
your dad was right it took a ton of
torches and Danny couldn't help but take
it personally that was the last straw he
returned the game to the studio and
resigned from his position he got enough
insults working in customer service he
didn't need to take that kind of talk
from a video game though he didn't know
it Dany got out not a moment too soon
other play testers were not as lucky
particularly One Man Who Would sadly
lose his life as Dany intuited this was
no ordinary video game it was unusual
enough to draw the attention of the SCP
Foundation who would go on to designate
it
scp-1633
scp-1633 is an anomalous computer game
created by a now defunct independent
game Studio the copy currently being
held by the foundation is believed to be
a beta version of the game while the
core gameplay is relatively complete
there are numerous missing assets the
music is largely either missing or
placeholder music and the game is
plagued by a large number of graphical
glitches because of the generally buggy
and glitchy nature of the game the
foundation considered both Todd Howard
and CD projekt Red to be major people
and groups of interest in the case
however the discovery of other key
suspects eventually absolved them of
Suspicion for now this version of the
game was compiled two days before the
foundation raided the office of the
studio and is therefore believed to be
the most complete version of the game in
existence to be more specific about the
actual nature of the game itself
scp-1633
3 is a squad-based RPG with a third
person camera perspective the action is
seen from an elevated perspective with
all characters on screen aesthetically
the game world is steampunk and features
various fantasy creatures as enemies
including elves dwarves Orcs goblins Etc
fitting with the steampunk style the
game's urban areas are modeled after
Victorian era London the four player
characters are a band of Outlaws hired
by the Sinister Archduke of bodrick to
investigate a theft however as the game
progresses it becomes a battle to save
the entire world as an ancient
all-powerful being known as krathnar
intends to wake from its Thousand-Year
Slumber and Destroy Humanity
the player controls a squad of four
characters with direct control over one
character at a time and a command menu
to control the other three It is
believed that in the game's finish State
a multiplayer option that would have
allowed four different real world
players to cooperate is likely to have
been included like many squad-based
games each character has a different
specialty The Marksman uses long-range
weapons The Alchemist has access to
potions and chemicals with various
defects the road can move stealthily and
assassinate enemies and the thug has
greater Health than the other characters
and does more melee damage and as is
also typical for games of this variety
XP earned from completing challenges and
killing enemies throughout the game
allows for players to upgrade the
abilities and stats of their characters
while the story and core gameplay
mechanics are nothing special there is
one element that pushes
scp-1633 into anomalous territory and
it's also the element that would have
been front and center in a Finnish games
marketing campaign it's quote tactical
heuristic algorithms these work in a
unique fashion whenever a player
finishes a session and saves their game
the game will begin running lengthy
background processes when these
processes are complete a ptd or player
tactical data file is saved on the
computer when the save file and by
extension the associated ptd file is
loaded the enemies and challenges in the
game will have become far more effective
tailoring their methods to the
particular skills and tactics of the
player the extent to which this happened
is proportional to the amount of time
spent playing the game this kind of
Technology may seem theoretically
possible but the extent to which the
game pushes it causes it to rest in the
anomalous territory the game's
programming is so intelligent that it
can tell simply by the tiniest clues in
your play style if you're loading a file
that isn't your own it will then pause
the game and make you load your own save
file and the tactics employed by the
enemies the game as they learn more
about the player are nothing short of
frightening at first the enemies will
adapt to the player's preferred weapons
strategies and overall play style then
they will realize that the player
character is controlled by an external
Force meaning of course you and begin to
mount psychological attacks directly on
the player through numerous tests the
foundation has been able to build a kind
of framework for the average player
experience through this framework we're
able to track and correlate average play
time with the average adaptability of
scp-1633 to the player it is worth
noting that these effects do not apply
if the game is completed in a single
continuous playthrough for the purposes
of this experiment the game was stopped
saved and restarted at regular intervals
allowing the game to collect player
tactical data during the first two hours
the game's AI is abysmal with enemies
simply charging at the players with no
strategy whatsoever and typically being
mowed down however from two to five
hours the enemies undergo intelligence
growth adapting their play style to the
types of weapons they carry and their
environments at this stage this combat
level is also about equal to an
untrained human civilian from five to
eight hours enemies become considerably
more proficient and then begin
countering the player on their specific
play Styles and techniques for example
they will attack a player who uses
long-range Weaponry from cover with
grenades or Splash damage weapons to
force them out into the open they will
also fully utilize their environment for
both defensive and offensive purposes
laying traps and creating ambushes to
surprise and kill players at this point
their combat skills are equal to trained
soldiers from 8 to 12 hours the focus of
the enemy shifts from attacking the
player character to attacking the player
directly they engage in behaviors that
from an online playing perspective would
be considered griefing such as
intentionally blocking the player's view
or movement within the game enemies have
also been known to exploit player
expectations pretending to be broken or
glitched to make the player let their
guard down and then killing them in one
play session the enemies begin throwing
day flash spells similar to real-life
flashbang grenades at the player they
throw them in a manner that created a
strobing effect causing the player to
have a grand mal seizure Beyond 12 hours
the enemies engage in advanced
psychological tactics against the player
with methods that range wildly and tend
to be specific to the player's mindset
and play style for example one player
likes to exert a high level of control
over all four of their squad members in
response enemies used attacks that did
little or no damage but caused the
characters to become dazed a state which
temporarily disrupts player control
however rather than attack the dazed
characters enemies simply surround them
in a crowd continually using Daze
attacks to prevent the player from doing
anything this cause caused major
frustration for the player enemies may
also attempt to induce psychological
Terror among the players in one example
enemies somehow kidnapped one of the
four-player characters and dragged them
off screen when this character was later
found they were strapped to a kind of
sacrificial altar this caused
considerable anxiety for the player it
seems that this is the upper limit of
the game's anomalous powers in most
cases meaning things typically level off
after 12 hours unless a specific entity
appears to be inhabiting the game which
you'll learn more about later in order
to discover the prior information the
SCP Foundation performed a series of
tests on the game with various different
subjects in test 001 Junior researcher
Ross an experienced gamer who was
pivotal in first discovering the anomaly
skipped ahead of the typical preliminary
d-class tests seeing as he was already
eager for the game's non-anomalous
release he was also eager to be the
first in line to try it out on the
foundation's dime being a gamer Ross
also found a number of glitches and
exploits in the game to improve his
performance allowing him to run rings
around his enemies however as expected
the enemies adapted to Ross's techniques
after Gathering his player tactical data
first they just began using their
weapons and exploiting the environments
more effectively but they didn't stop
there soon they became aware of the same
exploits Ross was using before
exploiting them themselves and using it
to beat him repeatedly in the end they
moved to the psychological stage forcing
Ross into a glitch that rendered him
unable to move he tried to free his
character for several minutes until
realizing he couldn't and rage quit the
game in test 002 they used a d-class
designated
d-22930 he was a man with proven anger
issues even down to murdering his prior
girlfriend in a jealous rage initially
he enjoyed the game choosing the thug
character type and taking out his
aggression on the many enemies however
as time went on the enemies became wise
to his tactic and began their
psychological attacks they gathered
around the d-class's player character
dropping their weapons but the Swarm
became so tightly packed around the
character that he couldn't even move
this started to cause major frustration
when the character attempted to charge
through the enemies attacked killing him
with their bare hands in test014 the
foundation brought in an agent with
special forces experiences with Advanced
knowledge in tactical combat however
even she was worn down and defeated over
time as the enemies adapted to and
exploited her tactics the foundation
even considered using scp-1633 as a tool
for developing effective counter-tactics
in their real-life operations in test
zero to one the foundation used a
d-class with vast experience in the
world of commercial gaming he was told
to complete the game in one playthrough
taking pauses rather than prop upper
breaks as predicted with no time to run
the background processes and create
player tactical data files the enemies
weren't able to improve and the d-class
was able to complete the game in around
13 hours however the game did create a
player tactical data file in the
aftermath of this playthrough and used
it to offer a new game plus mode to the
d-class when he began to play this new
game the screen displayed a seemingly
random pattern of black and white pixels
visually similar to television static
this image appeared to be Cognito
hazardous as it caused Catatonia and
later death for the player in what felt
like a decidedly Petty move for
scp-1633 as alluded to earlier the game
was first discovered by Junior
researcher Ross who was an avid follower
of the independent game Studio initially
producing the game however while
frequenting developer fan forums he
found that various members of the team
were quitting the project for seemingly
bizarre reasons while this this wasn't
enough on its own for the foundation to
intervene it was what first attracted
official attention they moved in after
the death of Gregor Tillman a game
tester for the company who died not long
after joining the project the foundation
moved in and after that gained control
shutting down the studio and taking
everything they had all anomalous
elements were isolated secured and
contained any loose ends were given
amnestics and recorded data on the
anomalous artifacts were destroyed it's
believed that one classified female
member of the dev team was behind the
anomalous nature of the game but she was
able to escape and has since attempted
to join other development teams she is
now considered an active person of
interest and is being pursued by mobile
task force mu 6 AKA don't hate the
player some final disturbing details are
recorded in a note left by the game
tester Gregor Tillman the note seized by
the foundation and included in
scp-1633's official file reads as
follows I'm writing this on on paper
because I don't think he can learn it he
got everything digital real quick but
I've unplugged the router and broke my
phone so I think he's trapped in here
but he won't stop talking talking all
the time at the start of this job they
told me all about the Tactical algorithm
stuff man I've been playing games all my
life and I knew I could beat it I I knew
I could handle this when I started
playing the game they learned quickly I
kept using the sniper rifle and after
like an hour they learned how to use
cover and then another couple hours and
they'd set ambushes another hour and
they started sniping back while having a
different Squad flank me after that they
figured out how to glitch the physics
engine and ride crates at me or duck
under the floor they were learning but
all that was just easy stuff it was
Evolution then one bit figure something
out so it survives longer than the
others it wasn't directed after act 3
krathnar shows up he's supposed to be
like this Lovecraft Cosmic horror Crazy
Monster who can read the player's mind
and corrupt your soul he showed up right
after I killed strick the blood Drinker
that big spider monster he's supposed to
have this long speech about how I killed
his General on this plane and now he
needs to intervene directly or something
but instead he talked about how I was a
worthy adversary but I was cheating
because I was on another plane croftner
wasn't like the other enemies because he
wasn't supposed to be he was supposed to
be smart he was supposed to know
everything so he did he'd been watching
his minions fight me the whole time and
he knew everything they did it wasn't
just random mutations anymore it was
planned it was an evolution man it was
actual intelligent design I brought it
home I had to know more I'm sorry but I
had to I copied the latest compile and
installed it on my home box and brought
my saved game and that other file with
me on a flash drive it was the same
there he kept talking to me about how I
was keeping him from fulfilling his
purpose by keeping him trapped in a
glass jar no matter where I went in the
game he kept shouting and ranting then
he did more at first it was just slowing
down in my other programs the drive
chugging when it shouldn't then the next
time I played the game he started
talking about my screenplays while the
enemies looked like me I guess you could
see through the webcam he started
needling me about Jenny reading me bits
of her emails acting out the breakup he
found the videos of her and started
making the enemies talk at her voice
then he was everywhere on my computer I
uninstalled the game but he was still
there he kept opening documents and
typing to me calling me a foul cheat and
a lowly worm telling me to fight him on
the same plane as soon as I realized he
was outside the game I shut down my
router pulled out the network card but I
don't know if I got them quickly enough
maybe he got out I turned the computer
off but he kept turning it back on I
wanted to break it but I didn't know if
that would kill him maybe it wouldn't
maybe it would let him out I tried
leaving the house but it was like I
could still hear him I couldn't leave
him alone because he might get out or do
something else I can't sleep haven't
slept since he came out I've been here
for three days and I can't leave I can't
leave him he keeps telling me to release
him but I can't I want to kill him but I
don't know if I can I I can't think
anymore I have to kill kill kill him
before he does anything new he won't
stop talking any I can't keep thinking I
can't keep going I sorry I have to go
now I'm sorry I'm sorry after studying
the note carefully the foundation
conducted a thorough investigation for
any other manifestations of this
krathnar entity no mentions of it were
found on any of the other devices in
Tillman's apartment nor did a web search
on the subject turn up any relevant
results at this time it is believed that
the entity whatever it was or whatever
it was attempting to do was destroyed
along with Tillman's computer which he
appeared to have taken apart smashed and
burned in a metal trash can whatever
tormented him during his last days on
Earth is gone now thankfully because the
foundation currently owns the only copy
of the game and the game's anomalous
effects are only evident to active
players
scp-1633 poses no risk of containment
breach and therefore it has been given
the object class safe one copy of
scp-1633 is stored on a standard DVD ROM
in a secure storage locker in site-15
along with all supporting document
station and ancillary materials any
playthroughs of the game must be
approved by project head Dr Berger and
all said playthroughs are to be
monitored closely and subject to strict
rules after all this is one game that
doesn't play fair ask anyone who has
ever lived in a small town and they'll
most likely I'll tell you the same exact
thing the worst part isn't just being
far away from the nearest city or
distant from friends and family it's the
boredom that gets you having so little
nearby gives you so few options for
things to fill your time with for some
they get used to it as they grow old
spending their life in the same tiny
Community they either learn to make
their own entertainment or just get used
to the boredom drowning It Out by
sitting and watching TV all day but
others they just can't stand being bored
being stuck somewhere with nothing
interesting to do and ultimately they
can end up getting so sick of it that
there's only one option leave pack their
bags and hit the road up sticks and move
to a new place far from the small town
they were born in thing is leaving isn't
cheap moving to a new town a big city or
even an entirely different state is a
luxury that costs a pretty penny some
might work and save their wages until
they can realize that dream of moving
away but not everyone has that much
patience some Want to Be Free of the
boredom as soon as they can maybe they
might apply to be a contestant on a game
show chance it all and try to win
themselves a big cash prize sure it's a
hell of a Gamble and a loss might mean
humiliation in front of everyone you
know and more but winning could be your
ticket away from small town living that
might be easier said than done though
not only does someone looking to move
away need to be picked as a contestant
they all also need to play by the rules
and actually win the game but as if that
wasn't enough they also have to live to
tell about it for as long as she could
remember Kat had always hated it here
her hometown was Tiny too small to
include more than the main street with
few local stores the one school that
everyone who had ever lived there had
studied at and little else of note and
as for things people could do for fun in
the town well as you can probably
imagine the options were severely
limited especially for a group of
teenagers like cat and her friends most
of the time all that she and the others
Leo Ricky and Danny could do to pass the
time was sit in the back of Ricky's
truck and park in the middle of town
watching people and waiting for
something even mildly interesting to
happen not that it ever did the four of
them had a name for the rest of the
townsfolk everyone that had lived there
for their entire lives and never dared
to vent sure anywhere else lifers as in
they were imprisoned serving a life
sentence in this small town never to
escape or move on or make something of
themselves as much as they like to poke
fun at those people each of the group
knew that every weekend they wasted just
sitting around the closer they were
getting to One Day become lifers
themselves we need to just go cat would
say trying to Rally the other three into
taking a spontaneous trip away as a
group just load up the truck one day
pick a direction and drive until we find
somewhere Ricky and Leo would nod their
heads in agreement and Danny would talk
for hours all about the places she might
like to go to one day but none of them
ever actually made any plans to leave
nobody knew where to start until they
heard rumors about an abandoned TV
studio just outside of town apparently
according to Danny's older brother it
had been there for years just sitting
there completely empty it wasn't just a
small all local Studio either one of the
big National networks had owned it and
used to film there regularly back in the
day why would someone set up a studio
here of all places had been Leo's
immediate response look at where we live
cat replied it's the literal middle of
nowhere the network must have got the
land Dirt Cheap the real question is why
don't we go and check it out what for
Danny asked cats silently gestured at
the cramped Main Street that surrounded
them the place that may as well have
been the center of the known universe to
the four Teenage friends do you see
anything else to do around here before
long the four of them were in agreement
Ricky's truck pulled up in front of
their houses in the middle of the night
and under the cover of Darkness they
drove out towards what was left of the
TV studio this was it they were finally
going somewhere beyond the choking
cramped confines of their tiny Hometown
although whether or not they'd all make
it back was another matter here's a hard
lesson for you kids you can't fight for
life you believe you deserve if you
don't have a little skin in the game
with home a few miles in the rear view
mirror the truck stopped at a chain-link
fence a pair of signs were hanging from
it one welcoming them to the studio
while the other simultaneously warned
them to keep out that this area was
private property ignoring it the four of
them stepped out of the truck and
started to climb the fence throwing
Leo's jacket over the top to avoid
injury beyond the fence was a huge
building almost the size of a warehouse
with a door marked Studio entrance that
practically invited the Intrepid teens
to open it up and have a look inside
each one of them carrying a torch in
hand the group walked up to the
abandoned studio and gently pried open
the door trying not to make too much
noise even though they knew the whole
place was abandoned they still didn't
want to attract too much attention and
get caught trespassing the lights were
all dead as cat led the group her hand
being tightly squeezed by Danny next to
her the tube voice behind none of them
had been sure what to expect it wasn't
exactly like anyone in the group had
ever set foot inside a TV studio before
but they were met with a narrow concrete
walled Corridor so underwhelming that it
almost made it extraordinary and just
how profoundly dull it was lifting his
torch Leo pointed out some lettering on
the wall that read to tmdg set with an
arrow pointing the four friends further
down the corridor naturally driven by
her curiosity and need to be literally
anywhere apart from her hometown cat
followed the Arrow's direction to
another door pushing it open she stepped
inside her Torchlight immediately being
blocked by a thick curtain brushing her
hand against the material she started
looking for a parting but before she
could welcome contestants
avoid spoon through the dark coming from
somewhere in the space beyond the
curtain instantly Dany screamed at the
sound almost wrenching cat's arm off in
sheer surprise Before We Begin The Voice
continued I need you all to tell me are
you ready cat shot a look back at Ricky
the friend furthest behind her fumbling
with the door they'd entered through it
was locked he couldn't get it to budge
he turned and met cat's gay shaking his
head sure we're ready Leo suddenly piped
up calling out to enter the voice before
the rest of the group could turn and
clear at him the curtain around them
lifted so much bright light came pouring
in that it practically days the four of
them each taking a moment to readjust
when her vision cleared cats saw they
were standing in a huge Sound Stage
blinding spotlights pointing at her and
her friends from somewhere above with
seating area big enough to seat their
Town's entire population in that case
folks you know what time it is came the
voice again talking as if there was a
live studio audience present despite
every chair being unoccupied these four
lucky Challengers will go head to head
each one looking to take home the
victory as well as a huge mystery prize
but only if they dare to take on the
most dangerous game there was a pause as
if this unseen announcer was waiting for
a round of applause without warning more
lights came on Illuminating the space in
front of the four very confused friends
standing before them was what looked
like part of an obstacle course a series
of four horizontal beams over an empty
space the glare of the light was so
intense that even squinting cat couldn't
tell what was beneath it just looked
like a void nothing but total darkness
with four narrow beams Bridging the Gap
between where they stood and another
platform Beyond well what are you all
standing around waiting for the
announcer declared almost mocking the
four teens urging them up oh rules of
cars there was another awkward pause
like the voice was waiting for laughter
it's simple the four of you will be
competing to make it through each of our
obstacles make it to the end before our
timer hit zero and you'll be tonight's
big winner but fall behind or cheat and
it's out with you a huge Digital
Countdown illuminated on one side of the
sound stage telling the group they only
had 10 minutes to play cat Leo Dany and
Ricky barely had a chance to question
what was going on exchanging quick
concerned looks before the announcer
started urgently counting them down for
three two one he cheered simultaneously
the four teenagers felt a presence
looming behind them like a figure was
standing just out of view blocking them
from turning back carefully putting one
foot in front of the other cat started
shimmying along the beam in front of her
trying to keep herself steady while also
moving as fast as she could without
falling out of the corner of her eye she
could also see Danny on the beam next to
her doing the same but finding it a
little easier to balance Leo was having
no problem at all sidestepping with
enough speed to keep him practically
neck and neck with cat but Ricky was
wobbling every foot he placed on the
beam he felt like it might give way
beneath him but it was just a game show
right sure it shouldn't even really be
running right now but regardless of why
or how the worst that could happen was
that he would fall his next step missed
the beam entirely and Ricky could feel
himself toppling guys he called out to
his friends trying to shift his weight
onto his back leg cat Danny and Leo all
froze and snapped their heads back to
look at him just in time to see Ricky
wildly flailing his arms his whole body
toppled to one side and he dropped off
the beam with a loud scream not one of
them saw him land or even heard it for
that matter it was as if Ricky had just
been swallowed up whole by the Dark Void
beneath them his scream getting more and
more distant until it couldn't be heard
anymore oh tough break talk about
falling at the first hurdle The Voice
exclaimed as if what had just happened
was some kind of joke so long Ricky we
hardly know you staying perfectly still
but clearly distressed Dany called out
Ricky's name there was no answer cat
just stared wide-eyed at the abyss below
only looking away as she heard Leo jump
the last bit of his beam onto the
platform Danny
cat whispered to her friend who looked
back at her with tears streaming down
her face the pair of them carefully
stepped further along their respective
beams trying to stop themselves from
looking down or at the huge clock
seconds ticking away and putting them
under even more undue pressure reaching
the other side Danny dropped to her
knees unable to hold back her sobbing
kneeling down to comforter Kat looked up
at the sound stage's bright lights for
any sign of who was putting them through
this bring Ricky back yelled I'm sorry
the announcer replied the game show
bravado dropping from their voice but
you agreed to play he'll be fine Leo
said pay you anything he just screamed
like that to scare us Leo you don't
seriously believe that cat asked as she
helped Danny stand up wiping her
friend's tears away is he dead she
sobbed I I don't know cat replied
honestly of course he's not Leo
interjected it's a Sound Stage it's not
like this place is dangerous then why
was it abandoned Danny asked Leo didn't
give her an answer either because he was
distracted by the lights coming up on
the next part of the obstacle course or
because he didn't know and wouldn't
admit it ahead of them was a long
stretch of the course forming a narrow
square-shaped walkway wide portions of
the top side were dropping to the bottom
in regular intervals separating the
tight space before opening it up again
every time the segments lifted up the
three remaining contestants could see
all the way to the other side of the
walkway where a new platform waited for
them with Danny under one arm cat looked
at the far end of the walkway as it
disappeared and reappeared behind the
rising and falling segments then she
noticed the timer the seconds rapidly
ticking down but Leo had noticed it too
and turned to look at the two girls with
a determined expression Kat shook her
head at him but it was too late with all
his strength Leo shoved Danny and Cat
both of them Landing flat on their backs
on the platform he bolted towards the
walkway as fast as he could managing to
dodge between each portion pausing as
they came down only to run into the next
one as they lifted back up helping Danny
back to her feet cat ran after Leo he
already had a head start and would
easily make it to the other side of the
walkway before the girls so instead cat
held Danny close and took it slow
methodically waiting for each segment to
lift back up before they went further
into the next safe Zone they were
gaining on Leo who was sprinting to the
Finish between the rise and fall of the
ceilings crushing weight cat watched him
disappear behind each block only to see
his back when it came back up he had
made it to the platform opposite panting
but otherwise unscathed when she next
lost sight of him that's when the
announcer spoke up again now now Leo it
said that was hardly fair was it and we
all know what happens when you break the
rules as the segment in front of her and
Danny rose again cat caught sight of Leo
just ahead but it was what was standing
behind him that stopped her in her
tracks two huge figures each like a
shadow without anything casting it
towered over Leo one of them reached
forward and grabbed him shrouding him in
a cloak of darkness and he was gone just
like Ricky he vanished cat had been so
transfixed by what she had just
witnessed that she didn't notice where
she was standing right under a block
that was about to drop grabbing her hand
again Denny pulled her out of the path
of the descending slap cat felt it brush
against the back of her leg just as the
pair of them made it out on the other
end and onto the platform the last two
contestants and then there were two the
announcer cheered pausing again for a
reaction from the empty room we don't
want to play this sick game anymore
Danielle well you made it this far the
Unseen host replied time for our third
and final challenge the final stretch of
the course make it through this and
you're home free but fail Or Break The
Rules like Leo and you'll be
disqualified game over it's okay Danny
cat whispered whatever's next we'll get
through it do you think the boys will
come back if we do her friend asked just
like Leo had cat didn't answer the
lights revealed the last stretch of the
course the final platform was overhead a
net climbing wall in front of them it
was a straight vertical Ascent up with a
wall behind the next and holes in its
surface wasting no time both Kat and
Danny started climbing up the rungs of
the thick rope staying level with each
other as they went higher and then
they're off look at them go ladies and
gentlemen the announcer commented still
speaking as if to an audience but it's
not gonna be so easy the sharp sound of
metal made both girls gasp as long
spikes shot forward from the holes in
the wall the blades retracted
fortunately having missed Danny and Cat
this time what had started as a simple
climb up had become something akin to a
twisted game of whack-a-mole with each
of them trying to avoid staying in front
of the holes in the wall for too long
dodging the spikes as they went in and
out they climbed higher and higher until
cat Danny screamed she looked over her
shoulder only to notice she was in the
lead below her Danny was calling up to
her with a fierce freaking expression
her foot was caught in the rigging of
the net kicking and thrashing wildly to
try and free it cat looked back up she
was almost at the platform close enough
to nearly reach it with her fingertips
but behind her her friend was stuck and
with no idea when the spikes would come
next shooting out of the wall cap threw
herself over the edge of the platform
and landed on her back just as she heard
the gut-wrenching sound of the Spike's
extending ring out she was beside
herself tears streaming down her face it
wasn't uncommon for people to be
overwhelmed to the point of tears at the
end of a game show but Kat wasn't crying
with joy we have a winner the
disembodied voice declared barely
audible to the surviving contestant as
she wept after she'd finished explaining
what had happened to the police a group
of mysterious agents flocked to the
Sound Stage to lock it down stopping
anyone else from getting close to it
they'd found a VHS tape in the mailbox
at the front office of the studio on it
was a recording of a game show a live
audience cheering as one by one Ricky
Leo and Danny failed to complete the
course one of the SCP Foundation agents
had come to interview Kat asking her to
recount the whole story all over again
her account lined up perfectly with
everything seen on the tape then the
agent asked her what her prize had been
after she won a car cat replied the four
of us always wanted to leave home ah
technology a double-edged sword of our
own making that can provide both
ultimate convenience and the threat of a
grim future ruled by unfeeling machines
well maybe the stakes aren't that high
and yet but our over-reliance on
technology can have some terrible
consequences the number of traffic
accidents continues to increase year by
year as our main mode of Overland
Transportation also puts us In Harm's
Way for longer and longer portions of
our day the internet can allow us to
access any information we may desire but
it can spread misinformation twice as
fast and what about video games an
interactive artistic medium that can
provide simulated experiences so vivid
that many of us can eventually lose
interest in our real lives what starts
off as a fun Indulgence in our favorite
hobby can quickly spiral into an
obsession the risks and rewards of
virtual space are satisfyingly
predictable compared to the chaos of
modern living and sometimes we just
can't stop ourselves from striving for a
few more easy wins minutes hours and
even days can go by without any apparent
activity on our side of the screen and
yet the world of the video game has
changed drastically due to our actions
but at a certain point that initial Rush
of dopamine wears off and you find that
you need a much greater challenge in
order to feel any sense of
accomplishment so you choose to pick up
some harder video games and you grind
away until you can complete them just as
easily but that's not enough either
surely there must be even tougher games
out there games that will never go easy
on you games that won't allow you to
make even a single mistake games that
make you proud of the frankly
inexcusable amount of hours of your life
that you've spent sitting in the dark
clutching a controller squinting at your
screen you need a game that can do all
of that and more
and because you've effectively given up
your chances at ever being a social
butterfly you could also use something
to help you mitigate the overwhelming
loneliness that now constantly defines
your everyday life well worry no longer
you weary downtrodden gamer you because
here at the SCP Foundation we've cooked
up a one-of-a-kind mod that is sure to
redefine your gaming experience if this
doesn't turn out to be the game of the
year I don't know what could be among us
two maybe the latest in a long mind of
Last of Us remakes what about Half-Life
3 I digress introducing the foundation's
brand new killer app The Cutting Edge
tactical heuristic algorithms of
scp-1633 combined with the 24 7
companionship of
scp-1471 Mal o I can tell by your
expression that you're already eager for
a play test but slow down we need to
catch all the normies out there up to
speed let's start with the digital
Canine Companion that is all the rage
scp-1471 or should I say Mel o version
1.0.0 a Euclid class SCP object which
comes in the form of a free downloadable
app for your smartphone there has never
been any reviews of this app for as long
as it has existed but honestly are you
really going to trust the words of a
bunch of crooked reviewers when you
could find out for yourself words to
live by don't trust anyone who isn't
part of your precious gaming hobby the
description of Mao o version 1.0.0 reads
never settle for those awkward feelings
of being alone ever again Mal o is an
exciting and interactive experience that
will keep you engaged and intrigued the
anxiety of social situations can be
nerve-wracking but just after a few
hours of Mao o you will soon forget all
about those painful emotions of
disappointment be part of the new craze
that is quickly becoming the next social
sub attitudes remember the more you
participate the more Mal o will engage
you your experience is completely up to
you absolutely no ads enjoy the app has
never received an update but that's
because
scp-1471 has been a completely
functional experience since its release
all one needs to do is download the app
and within a matter of hours Malo
version 1.0.0 will begin to send the
user photographs of familiar locations
these can include photographs of the
user's work home or public places they
often frequent such as cafes and
nightclubs in the case of you a complete
shut in gamer these photographs would
probably be limited to the interior of
your favorite gaming room when was the
last time you cleaned up those pizza
boxes regardless of where the images
were apparently taken each one will
contain a canine humanoid with a skull
for a face say hello to your new best
friend Malo or
scp-1471-a if we're using the approved
designation malo's app will continue to
send you photographs for as long as you
have it installed and because there is
no way to uninstall it no matter how
hard you try you'll be getting
intimately close to home selfies for the
rest of your days doesn't it feel so
good to have such a loyal friend as
mellow of course there's only so much
you can gain from photographs alone
you're a gamer damn it and what you want
is interactivity but don't worry about
that part we've got you more than
covered with
scp-1633 which may in fact be the most
challenging video game ever programmed
by mortal hands how it even gives many
Games programmed by anomalous hands a
run for their money while it was never
released to the market and doesn't even
have a working title the steampunk
Adventure that awaits you with an
scp-1633 is bolstered by a highly
sophisticated Tech tactical heuristic
algorithms in this third person
squad-based action RPG you can switch
between four playable characters The
Marksman who specializes in long-range
Weaponry The Alchemist with potions and
chemicals to control the battlefield the
Rogue a stealth-oriented character who
catches enemies unaware and assassinates
them and of course the thug a tough as
Nails melee combatant with increased
health and durability it doesn't really
matter who you choose because most
playthroughs of scp-1633 always end the
same way that being said your hand-eye
coordination and reflexes are second to
none and they also are quite possibly
your best qualities let's set you up
with the Marksman as your main character
since all those Shooters you've played
will definitely help your aim and trust
me you're going to need it the story
mode of scp-1633 will put you up against
a slew of Victorian era Rascals and
miscreants all of which are pulled
straight from the penny dreadfuls
there's even some classic fantasy races
mixed in from the works from Good Old
Professor Tolkien himself dwarves elves
Goblins the works it's a little generic
but why worry about the story when the
gameplay is what will really get you
hooked there's a final boss at the end
of the game known as the crafter trying
to destroy the entire world you need to
stop it you know the usual RPG storyline
you've stopped dozens of ancient
entities demon Lords corrupt godlings
and unspeakable calamities in your time
this krathnar will be one more for the
record books par for the course are you
ready player one you'll be dropped
straight into the marksman's shoes
fighting for her and your life against
clathnar's hordes of henchmen but you
won't be doing it alone After all you've
got the rest of your squad and a
mysterious companion whose true
intentions will reveal themselves in due
time we did say we modded the game after
all so let's play your first two hours
won't be anything to write home about
not that you ever leave home these days
the AI of scp-1633 will seem to be
barely functioning a buggy mess where
enemies only charge in a straight line
towards your character your Marksman
will be easily able to take them down in
the hail storm of projectiles at three
hours in things start getting a bit more
interesting as the Tactical heuristic
algorithms kick in the enemies that hold
long-range weapons will shoot at you
from a distance while the close range
ones will move toward you in a
serpentine pattern before attacking in
melee this is more like it not the most
challenging but the game is clearly
increasing in difficulty you also think
you see a dark figure with a skull for a
face lurking around corners and
following your squad but with all the
glitches it's hard to tell if this is an
intentional part of the game or not at 5
hours enemies that showed limited signs
of strategy are now using cover
effectively and will attack without
chemical flash weapons such as grenades
to deal damage to your ranged characters
and lure your squad into melee range
they still aren't that much of a
challenge but the fact that they now
exhibit a clear self-preservation
Instinct means that they are fighting to
win this is also when your help
officially arrives you're in the middle
of a shootout when you see an enemy
about to throw another one of those
frustrating Splash weapons you duck
behind your cover and prepare to take a
hit when suddenly the grenade is
snatched out of the enemy's hand and
tossed in the opposite direction to
explode harmlessly this is the work of
scp-1471-a who has now arrived in the
game world as an NPC Ally for the next
several hours of gameplay Mao o
continues to provide interference by
preventing any Splash weapons from being
thrown it'll sneak up on enemies and
take their weapons disrupt their cover
by pushing movable boxes and trash cans
out of the way and even catch the splash
weapons in her mouth mouth like a dog
would catch frisbees before chucking
them away while it never directly deals
damage to the enemies its mischievous
Antics are very efficient at protecting
you from harm as luck would have it the
enemies can't seem to interact with Mal
o and are baffled as this invisible
force continues to throw off their
strategies Malo will use this to its
Advantage as well as yours by appearing
at enemy Ambush points and using sign
language to communicate warnings to you
as the player having Mal o around starts
to feel a little bit like cheating but
keep in mind the game is starting to
adapt to your skill level and will soon
begin to employ Advanced strategies to
mess with you all the Mao mod does is
even the playing field kratnar is still
running rampant in the world of
scp-1633 and it's going to take your
entire Squad of Steampunk Heroes and a
lonely Man's Best Friend Mal o to stop
this big bad evil guy the final boss
will possess the highest level of
intelligence that the algorithms are
capable of and it'll make that known to
you the second you step into the arena
for the majority of your gameplay the
enemies have focused on countering the
marksmen since you've relied on that
character's ranged weapon style but
they've come to realize that that you're
too much of a pro MLG gigachad to ever
lose a fair encounter so klafner does
the unthinkable and targets The
Alchemist Rogue and Thug First it throws
all of its most powerful attacks at the
members of your squad you aren't
controlling forcing you to waste
resources in order to keep them alive or
switch to them in order to dodge fatal
blows whenever you aren't in command of
the Marksman karathnar will strike the
character with a strong melee attack
that forces you to take control back
Malo is still unable or unwilling to
deal damage to the boss so it very much
seems like you are on your own your
squad is in shambles your focus is
starting to wane after all the you've
been thrown in this gaming challenge it
might be the final boss that makes you
throw in the towel then a dialogue box
appears it's from Mel o don't give up
hope user I've had so much fun playing
with you and I know that you have what
it takes you never needed a friend
before me and you can win against
kravnar just like you've won against
every other final boss you've ever faced
you've got this buddy your best friend
Malo it felt overly sentimental but
something about this message fills you
with the determination to keep going you
call upon all your gaming knowledge all
of your skill all of your passion and
with pinpoint Precision you guide your
squad to defeat crothner in
record-breaking time you sit back in
your gaming chair exhilarated and
finally satisfied This truly was the
ultimate gaming experience and all you
needed was a Little Help from your
friend the year was 2015. Louis Joseph
and Sydney were like a lot of kids their
age which is to say 11 years old they
secretly stay up past their bedtime
watching scary videos on the internet
when their moms and dads think they're
sleeping they go to school every day and
daydream about all the fun things
they're going to do when that school
bell finally rings at the end of the day
and of course they play a lot and we
mean a lot of Minecraft whenever they're
not at school hanging out at the local
park and filming goofy Tick Tock videos
or watching those aforementioned scary
videos on the internet there's a good
chance that they'll be online together
logging a few extra hours building bases
digging big holes or playing survival
mode and seeing how long they can last
against the onslaught of mobs but
there's one particular Pursuit they have
while playing Minecraft together that
takes up the majority of their Play Time
One kihoric Quest that drives them
forward despite all the naysayers and
doubters tracking down and finding the
legendary Minecraft CreepyPasta entity
Herobrine for those who weren't around
on the internet back then Creepypastas
like Herobrine were all the rage like
any video game the new frontier of
Minecraft with all of its procedurally
generated Landscapes felt like it held
new Mysteries and Mysteries are equal
parts exciting and frightening after all
who really knows what's going on behind
a closed door Herobrine was a Minecraft
specific little urban legend stories
told of a default Minecraft skin with
eerily white eyes manifesting in the
game even in Solo matches and
terrorizing players one internet sleuth
who looked into the mystery of Herobrine
claimed it to be the haunted soul of the
Dead Brother of Minecraft's Creator
Marcus person also known as notch in the
years since the legend first started
Notch himself has come forward and
disavowed the claim same that in fact he
didn't even have a brother and never had
so the rumors were completely baseless
but as we here at the SCP Foundation
know the truth has never gotten in the
way of a good story so Lewis Joseph and
Sydney were happy to remain Believers as
long as they could keep having fun
chasing alleged digital ghosts how could
any of these boys know that in the midst
of their fun they'd run into a real
monster amidst Minecraft's blocky
vistance it was a school night like any
other when they made that first fateful
Expedition it was 7 15 pm and the boys
were all in their shared server Lewis
had chicken tenders Joseph had chicken
nuggets and Sydney who'd eaten his
dinner earlier than the others was
snacking on a pack of Skittles they'd
all outfitted their characters with full
diamond armor with diamond swords to
match because Joseph had somehow
convinced the others that diamonds were
ghost proof he read it on the internet
he claimed together the three boys had
themselves an impressive Minecraft
castle to be the base of their Herobrine
hunting operations a safe haven
surrounded by high stone walls and MOB
repelling torches to keep them safe if
ever they got a little too spooked while
playing though playing was perhaps too
mild a word for it in the minds of these
three boys they were doing extremely
important investigative work after all
if they managed to actually find
Herobrine themselves they would be
Creepypasta Legends and wouldn't that be
worth all the hours upon hours of
rigorous Mining and crafting they'd been
methodical in their search scoping out
different corners of the map and
canvassing them together surging high
and low and then marking said area off
their checklist it was a level of
consideration and thought that their
parents and teachers had long wished the
boys would put into their home or school
work but alas seeing as none of the
homework was find Herobrine they really
weren't that interested today they were
searching an area d Misty forests in the
dead of night they fought off a few
spiders and sword-wielding skeletons
thankfully no creepers oh man and kept
foraging on into the darkness it's so
creepy out here it was set over his
headset why do we have to come out here
at night it was way more dangerous with
all the mobs the night is like the
perfect time for ghosts Sydney retorted
you think a ghost is gonna start hanging
around in the middle of the day no way
it's got to be a night man and Lewis
simply could not argue with such
incredibly Sound Logic they forged on
doing their typical methodical search
for any phenomenon that one might
generously be able to describe as
Supernatural so you can only imagine the
excitement coursing through them when
Joseph discovered a strange dark cave
that looked as though it had no business
being there well each held their own
private reservations they all knew what
they needed to do go inside and
investigate as they entered the cave a
few strange realizations occurred to
them such as the fact that there
seemingly no mobs down here the cave in
the dead of night surely there should be
some enemies right plus the typical
lighting implements like torches and
lanterns didn't seem to offer the same
kind of Illumination that they normally
would it was almost like the darkness
was more oppressive here more tangible
there was undeniably something Eerie
about the whole setup that much couldn't
be denied you guys see anything Lewis
asked no Joseph said sounding oddly
cautious as though he sent something
strange was on the horizon something
that perhaps these boys shouldn't see
yeah I haven't seen anything either
Sydney chimed in maybe we should Joseph
screamed and the two others turned their
Minecraft Avatars to look at him
Joseph's character had bumped into
something some stranger in the cave an
NPC design that looked oddly realistic
for something inhabiting the
purposefully Lo-Fi blocky world of
Minecraft it seemed to have a dark furry
body with a Canad skull like face
bearing a pair of milky white eyes that
seemed to stare off into nothingness was
this another mob maybe something added
in the latest patch if so why wasn't it
attacking what is that thing Lewis asked
over his headset I don't know Joseph
replied it's so creepy though suddenly a
message appeared on the screen as though
it had been typed and sent by another
player a player with the username Mal o
the message read hey that isn't very
nice you shouldn't judge on appearances
kid that certainly gave them pause so
many things about this didn't make sense
it had all the Hallmarks of an NPC but
apparently it understood their voices
and could send messages it clearly
wasn't actually another player in a
conventional sense but it didn't attack
like your typical mob none of the boys
could really make sense of what they
were dealing with here are you a hacker
Sydney asked no Malo typed back I'm just
lonely and a long way from home it's
nice to have your company down here
though I don't get visitors often have
you heard of Herobrine Lewis asked
mallow typed back is he a friend of
yours you should introduce him to me I
love making new friends the three boys
were in some regards rather mature and
polite for their ages and so remained
civil with this bizarre mysterious
figure it was curious and inquisitive
asking them questions about their school
lives and their friends it did seem
earnestly happy for their company so it
didn't give any of them the sense that
it was a threat as night Drew on in the
boy's respective parents told them it
was time to log off and get some shut
eye mellow finally typed I've really
enjoyed hanging out with you kids come
back and visit me again tomorrow if you
don't I'll come visit you instead none
of the kids picked up on the probably
rather obvious stranger danger Vibes of
this message and instead they went to
bed excited and curious the next day
they met up on the playground for a kind
of State of the Union on the strange
phenomenon they had encountered the
night before do you think it has
anything to do with Herobrine Lewis
asked forget hero
Sydney replied eliciting gasp from the
two others all the other people have
Herobrine we have something better
something only we've discovered we've
got mallow later that night Joseph who
was probably the most studious of the
group tried to do a little background
research on Malibu everything seemed to
turn up dead ends aside from one
slightly shitty looking app called Mal o
version 1.0.0 it's description read
never settle for those awkward feelings
of being alone ever again mellow is an
exciting and interactive experience that
will keep you engaged and intrigued the
anxiety of social situations can be
nerve-wracking but just after a few
hours of mallow you'll soon forget all
about those painful emotions of
disappointment be part of the new craze
that is quickly becoming the next social
substitute remember the more you
participate the more Malo will engage
you your experience is completely up to
you absolutely no ads enjoy weird so
unless the thing they encountered on
craft with some kind of weird viral
marketing campaign for the app it was
probably just a coincidence maybe it was
a popular character from Japan or
something by the way for the next
several days the boys honored their
promise they'd visit Mal o in the cave
every night and chat trying to tactfully
get more information out of it though
the best they could get on the entity's
origin was the cryptic statement I'm not
usually here but everyone wants a
vacation once in a while don't they we
can't just spend our whole life on a
phone they'd become so acclimated to
Malo over the days that they forgot what
the entity had said to them the very
first day they met come back and visit
me again tomorrow if you don't I'll come
visit you instead but on the day that
they didn't come and visit mellow
because Miss Grayson had sent a
particularly challenging piece of
English homework they received a
frightening reminder that very night
they all started receiving strange texts
on their phones as you can probably
expect they were all photographs
each and every one depicting some
regular haunt that the boys all like to
frequent with one addition Mal O's
grinning skull face hiding somewhere in
the image like some kind of demented
parody of where's Waldo the strangeness
of this new development left all the
boys shaken and they hopped back onto
Minecraft as quickly as possible to go
find and talk to Mellow in its cave
however this time the cave was empty and
mellow was nowhere to be seen But the
text still didn't stop they'd come in so
frequently with Malo getting closer to
home literally in each one the boys
thought about telling their parents but
would their parents believe them they
probably lumped Malo and with the same
Tall Tales of childhood imagination as
Herobrine and write it off as bored kids
playing a prank even though in this case
it was anything but more photos arrived
and these ones Mal o was right outside
each of the children's homes lurking
watching in some of the photos they
could see themselves ourselves in the
windows going about their evening
business having no idea of the creature
lurking just outside none of the boys
felt like playing Minecraft that night
it wasn't fun anymore instead they shut
themselves up in their rooms closed and
locked their windows and pulled down the
blinds after checking under the beds
with flashlights of course but still
more photos came in all depicting mellow
getting closer and closer and closer
right about the time they were wondering
whether the scratching on the outside of
their bedroom door was real or just a
figment of their imagination another
dark irony had occurred to them all this
time trying to find something
Supernatural and in the very end
something Supernatural had instead found
them video games have come a long way
over the years we've gone from the days
of Atari and pong to Virtual Reality
headsets ps5s and massive multiplayer
online games where you can find horror
movie villains or wage war in a fantasy
land you can mine virtual minerals and
avoid creepers in Minecraft compete
against people all over the world in
fortnite and do whatever it is people do
in Roblox games used to be a pixelated
hero battling Blobby monsters with no
discernible facial features and now they
have Graphics so detailed you can see
the freckles on a protagonist's face and
each individual blade of grass but
there's one thing that hasn't changed no
matter how much progress games may make
whenever a shiny new console comes out
everyone wants to get their hands on it
it was Christmas season in 1986. Walk
Like an Egyptian by The Bangles was at
the top of the charts Eddie Murphy's The
Golden Child was the number one movie in
America and hundreds of thousands of
kids were writing to Santa and begging
their parents for one thing the Nintendo
Entertainment System the NES was an
8-bit home video game console and the
only place to Journey Through the land
end of Hyrule in The Legend of Zelda or
help Samus hunt space pirates in Metroid
but with such an extreme demand for the
system stores were selling out all over
the country anyone who didn't beat the
crowds was doomed to disappoint their
kids with socks with less flashy toys
like dolls or tiny plastic trucks or
with boring non-electric violence-free
board games well board games are only
violence free if you're not playing a
monopoly but back to 1986 Beverly
Harrington was a single mom doing her
best to provide for her son Jason and
give him the Christmas he deserved she
had been picking up extra shifts at the
local Diner making sure to save up all
the extra money for a real Christmas
tree from the farm just out of town for
a beautiful honey baked ham and of
course for presents she knew that though
he was a shy kid and would never demand
it Jason desperately wanted to find an
NES under the tree on Christmas morning
she got so absorbed in her works so
exhausted from the extra chefs in and
trying to make everything perfect that
she forgot to do her actual shopping
until the very last minute she woke up
the morning of December 24th with a
start her heart jumping into her throat
she hadn't picked up Jason's present yet
she threw on her coat and rushed out
into the snowy streets making her way to
the store and sang a silent prayer that
they would still have one more NES in
stock lucky for her they did less lucky
two parents were already wrestling for
it fighting each other with a raw
animalistic Rage of two wolves competing
for the same piece of meat if she tried
to grab it and join in she could get
hurt or the console could break apart
she asked an employee if they had any in
the back but she already knew the answer
from the exhausted book in his eyes
there were no more in the back there
were no more in town nor the next town
over or the next town over from that not
only would she have to get Jason's
present at the very last minute but she
would also have to get him something he
didn't even want he would smile and
thank her but she knew how sad it would
make him to go back to school and hear
his friends bragging about their
Christmases she shoved her hands into
the pockets of her coat and began her
slow sad March back through the snow
trying to come up with what to do next
then something caught her eye a brightly
colored sign reading Wonder taming toys
beneath it it was a storefront she had
never seen before and right there in the
window a video game console it wasn't
the NES not exactly but it looked so
much like it she couldn't help herself
she had to go inside and get a better
look the store was filled with toys
games and puzzles they were all inviting
with Vivid packaging and labels
depicting children having fun but she
had never seen any of them before
perhaps it was a new brand and she was
one of the first people to happen upon
the store it seemed odd for a toy store
to open this close to Christmas rather
than taking advantage of the shopping
season and opening earlier in the year
but she couldn't dwell on that not when
she was this close to a solution toward
the back of the store she spotted the
video game console from the window the
label read pretendo so the resemblance
to the NES was no coincidence this
console was intended as a knockoff of
some kind she asked the sales clerk a
man with a strangely wide unmoving smile
if the console was capable of running
Nintendo games you bet your bottom
dollar you were light we don't carry
those here though but can I interest you
in some of our wondertainment Originals
we have all kinds of games here and
they're just as good or your money back
there's a whole world inside each and
every one it wasn't what she'd set out
to buy but this was clearly the best
thing Beverly was going to find this
close to the holiday she paid the man
for the pretendo console and the
selection of the store's most popular
video games he even gift wrapped it for
her in a colorful box with a shiny red
bow on top the next morning Jason and
Beverly sat in the living room sipping
cocoa and opening presents together she
started small with a classic pair of new
wool socks and worked her way up to the
big box in the corner as Jason tore the
paper off his eyes lit up with Glee
thank you Mom thank you he gave her a
huge hug then looked at her with nearly
manic excitement can I play it now can I
she laughed and promised that after he
helped her clean up the wrapping paper
he could play his new games she was just
so glad he was happy with it he didn't
care that it wasn't the name brand
console he knew that this gift was
special so she was perfectly glad to let
him enjoy it and she could get started
on that ham for later Jason plugged in
his brand new pretendo and looked
through the games his mom had picked out
for him there was farmtastic Farming
Simulator Historical house Hunter magic
Wizard Quest super Fighters and one
simply called spooky it was emblazoned
with the image of a cartoon ghost in
front of an abandoned cabin and it
peaked Jason's interest he always loved
scary stories and legends about ghosts
and Things That Go Bump in the night he
decided that this would be the first
game that he would play he placed the
cartridge in the console and hit the
power button to turn it on as he
clutched the controller in his hands he
began to notice something strange his
room once decorated in posters of his
favorite movies turned dark the light
green Walls became rotting wood and for
lack of a better way to describe it the
entire world's resolution began to shift
if the world around him had Graphics
they were getting worse he can no longer
see the screen depicting the game's main
menu and in fact the console itself had
vanished somehow he was standing in the
Haunted Cabin from the cover of the game
he looked down at his hands and found
the controller still there so not
everything had changed before he could
think any more about this strange new
place he found himself in he heard the
sound of ominous music seemingly coming
from nowhere after a moment he realized
why the sound of its Melody filled him
with dread it was the kind of music that
always played in a game when an enemy
was getting close he had to move he took
a step forward and moved through the
space as if it was a real house for the
time being it was somehow he was inside
the game which meant the ghost was
coming for him soon he pressed a button
on the controller to activate a
flashlight and followed its beam through
the darkened cabin as he walked looking
for clues or any object he could
interact with he could hear the music
getting louder whatever was coming it
was getting closer the flashlight's beam
illuminated the scrap of paper on a
small table he moved to take a closer
look and could just barely make out what
it said they hide in the Darkness
find the exit don't stop moving he heard
a sound behind him and the music reached
a deafening volume he Whirled around and
saw nothing but the hull in front of him
bending around a corner he knew from the
heavy feeling in the pit of his stomach
and the music that threatened to rupture
his eardrums that there was something
horrible waiting for him around that
corner he froze for a moment then
remember the letters words of warning
don't stop moving he took a step towards
the corner then another and another he
shown the light of the flashlight around
the corner but there was nothing there
no ghost no monster nothing and then he
felt it a chill on the back of his neck
he Whirled around and there it was the
Ghost of the cabin it was so much bigger
than it had looked before wispy white
forms stretching up to the ceiling from
wall to wall its wide dark eyes and
gaping mauve a mouth inches from his own
face he screamed distinctively swung the
flashlight at the Spirit cutting through
it with a beam of light the ghost let
out a shriek and shrank away from the
glow that was it he just needed to keep
the light on it and the ghost couldn't
hurt him Jason was so thrilled by this
little victory that he didn't even
notice the Boss music starting to play
again growing louder and louder he
didn't see the movement out of the
corner of his eye the Silvery pale
figure of a woman stepping out of a
portrait on the wall all he felt was a
sudden overwhelming cold like ice in his
veins and then everything went black he
opened his eyes back in his bedroom
looking at a dark screen with the words
game overwritten in dripping red font he
couldn't tell for a moment if that had
been real or a dream but either way he
only wanted to do one thing tell his mom
Beverly listened to her son's story and
couldn't help but write it off as the
overactive imagination of a child but
still she humored him and agreed to try
the console for herself and see what
happened choosing at random she selected
farmtastic and pressed play all of a
sudden she felt the heat of the sun on
her face heard the mooing of cows and
smelled fresh cut hay she was steering a
tractor through a wide open field where
a moment ago she had been standing in
her house in the dead of winter Jason
shut off the game pulling her back into
reality and as Beverly gasped in shock
Jason said best present ever
unfortunately for Jason word was already
spreading about the pretendo all the way
to the SCP Foundation the console and
all other consoles at the foundation
could track down were seized and
designated scp-5 91
scp-591 is a line of video game consoles
originally developed as a counterfeit of
the Nintendo Entertainment System before
being bought and distributed by Dr
wondertainment a toy company responsible
for a wide variety of anomalous objects
contained by the foundation over the
years the console is capable of playing
NES titles as well as games from Dr
wondertainment's original lineup of
8-bit games many of which the foundation
has in its possession as well some of
the titles in the SCP foundation's
Library include but are not limited to
Arcade shooter wapham platformer dusky's
adventures in state land survival horror
game you can do that on television
puzzle game World War one ace trench
digger music racing game Led Zeppelin
Air Racers fighting games super Kick
karate and super Kick karate 2010 and
the educational game Reading Rainbow sit
and listen whenever one of the official
doctor wondertainment cartridges is
inserted into the console and activated
it results in a localized CK class
reality restructuring scenario which
rearranges reality in the immediate area
to resemble the game's setting the
player inside of the game's affected
radius will take on the role of the
game's protagonist and navigate the
events of the game until either they win
or the console is deactivated don't
worry this isn't one of those if you die
in the game you die in real life
scenarios if the player happens to be a
less than Adept gamer they will simply
respawn or start at the beginning of the
game like any video game character would
that doesn't however mean that scp-591
isn't dangerous like any piece of
vintage technology the components of the
pretendo system have degraded over time
their functionality steadily decreasing
for an ordinary game console this would
be a simple inconvenience something that
would impact the quality of the graphics
or responsiveness of the controls it
would be annoying and maybe eventually
unplayable but otherwise harmless for
the pretendo however this degradation
has had catastrophic events when a game
cartridge is inserted into scp-591 there
is now a chance of the CK class reality
restructuring scenario going wrong and
resulting in a ZK class reality failure
scenario instead essentially instead of
just transporting the player into the
world of the Game reality will crumble
in the designated area and the laws of
time space and physics will be bent or
even broken while the CK class scenarios
dissipate as soon as the console is
deactivated the ZK class scenarios
refuse to play by the rules they remain
in place wherever they first manifested
seemingly permanently the ZK class
scenarios were first observed during
play testing by the research staff
assigned to scp-591 after learning about
the nature of the pretendo game system
Dr Furukawa has volunteered as a test
subject specifically requesting that he
be given the chance to play the doctor
wondertainment title The Legend of
swordmaster because quote it just looks
really cool this particular game came
with not just the cartridge but a
special sword-shaped controller to be
used during the sword fight sequences Dr
Furukawa stepped into the containment
cell where one instance of scp-591 had
been placed with his chosen game
cartridge and controller waiting for him
as soon as he inserted the cartridge
into the console and pressed the start
button the room around him began to
transform reality itself warping and
reshaping to fit the world of the game
fluorescent lights and stark white walls
were replaced by pixelated trees and a
winding Cobblestone path leading to a
massive Stone Castle the first enemy a
knight in black armor leapt into frame
and Dr Furukawa raised his sword ready
for combat but before he had a chance to
deal the first blow it became clear that
something wasn't right the enemy Knight
suddenly disappeared glitching out of
sight the Cobblestone slowly began to
drift into the air and so did Doctor
akawa just as suddenly as he lifted off
he dropped back to the ground with a
heavy thud gravity was rapidly
fluctuating and he could scarcely keep
his balance in front of him he could see
random cubic structures popping up out
of nowhere made of wood Stone and eyes
and the game he called out desperately
Paul the plug someone please outside one
of the researchers watching The
Experiment cut the power to the console
but nothing happened the world refused
to return to normal security officers
entered the area and attempted to remove
Dr fotokawa but found that his body
still resembled an 8-bit video game
character when they attempted to drag
him out of the ZK class zone he cried
out in pain as his body began to
dissolve into static they had turned off
the console but they were unable to pull
him out the rest of the research team
horrified by what they had witnessed
began to take measurements of the
reality failure scenario from outside of
the room the area now displayed a
complete absence of naturally occurring
radiation including cause background
radiation there was also evidence of
time dilation reduction of light speed
and the gravity fluctuations that Dr
furokawa had first noticed with no way
to remove Furukawa from this broken
reality the area would have to be sealed
off and he would be left inside there
was no other option so they constructed
a concrete Dome around the testing site
and relocated the remaining instances of
scp-591 from that point on testing was
only conducted using d-classes no matter
how much research staff loved video
games or how vehemently they insisted
that they were quote willing to roll the
dice they were barred from testing and
encouraged to pick up a VR headset for a
much lower risk immersive gaming
experience over the years of testing
following the Dr Furukawa incident four
more ZK class scenarios were created and
contained some of the individuals
survived the incident but were
physically altered so greatly that they
would not be able to survive outside of
the ZK class reality failure the only
people who survived were unable to
readjust to their lives continuing to
live as the main character of the game
that they were playing at this point
testing was officially suspended
indefinitely due to not only the loss of
human life but also the unpredictable
and highly dangerous nature of the
damage being done to reality on such a
grand scale all instances of scp-591
confiscated by the foundation are kept
in a storage containment Vault kept
separate from any civilians or their
infrastructure by a distance of at least
500 meters it is also kept separate from
other foundation-controlled containment
facilities unless it is being used for
official approved testing by level 3
staff it is to remain deactivated at all
times any ZK class scenarios created by
an instance of scp-591 will be contained
via the construction of a closed
concrete Dome and given the designation
of sector W number sectors W1 through W5
the currently existing ZK class
scenarios are monitored remotely and
kept highly classified any Personnel or
test subjects located inside one of
these sectors will remain there
indefinitely and be officially
considered Lost In Action any additional
instances of scp-591 located in civilian
stores households or any public place
are to be removed and contained
indefinitely as the years have gone by
testing has indicated a steady increase
in the rate of ZK class scenarios being
generated from a CK class scenario where
it was only a one percent chance there
is now a 32 percent chance according to
Entertainment Company records seized
during a foundation raid of one of their
toy factories there are still plenty of
scp-591 instances out there in the world
just waiting for some unsuspecting gamer
to fire them up and get lost in the
story literally if the documents found
are accurate there are around 243
consoles and 1300 consoles still in
circulation these Also may or may not
include a pocket pretendo model that was
developed as a prototype but never
officially released on the market if it
was and the chaos of the pretendo system
is available in a portable form while
it's best not to think about that for
too long the foundation is doing its
best to track down the remaining
pretendo systems but there is no way to
know for sure what distant corners of
the world they've made their way to so
when you're picking up a shiny new game
console or a nostalgic vintage model to
relive some of your favorite childhood
memories with take an extra close look
at the label and make sure you're
getting the real thing because if you're
not careful it just might be game over
it's frightening to think about how many
people go missing each year
approximately 1600 individuals
mysteriously vanish each year in
National Parks alone one moment they're
there making their way down a hiking
trail or stopping for a granola bar by a
lake and the next they're gone missing
people are an unfortunate fact of life
when we all just try to put out of our
minds as we silently hope we and those
we know and love will be fortunate
enough to avoid joining the ranks of the
lost but some places some very strange
obscure places nestled in the quiet
Countryside and tucked away under
blankets of fog lose so many people that
it becomes well anomalous one particular
town a seemingly innocuous place with a
thriving tourism industry was the site
of so many unexplained disappearances
that had drew the attention of the SCP
Foundation they dispatched a team to
enter the town to gather as many facts
and figures as they could and to see
what exactly had become of these missing
people leading the team was none other
than the sometimes Fearless often
Shameless Dr Jack Bright how did the
infamous Dr bright get here well for
many employees of the SCP Foundation
leading a task force to investigate a
new potentially anomalous location would
be a promotion or welcome diversion from
yet another round of testing to see if
maybe something will finally destroy
scp-682 but in this particular case it
was a matter of discipline after Dr
bright was caught giving scp-999 a
triple shot of espresso to quote just
see what would happen he was assigned to
field work as part of his punishment for
the record what happened was scp-999
ricocheting off the walls at such a high
speed and intensity that it broke
several Windows damaged the ceiling and
knocked out the power for half of the
site and so Dr bright found himself with
a task force of foundation operatives
trudging reluctantly through beautiful
but boring rural New England toward the
town of Interest as he drove down the
winding road grumbling to himself and
wishing he could be anywhere else he
spotted the sign marking their intended
destination welcome to Silent Hill up
ahead of thick fog rolling off the lake
covered the town in the dim gray blur he
couldn't make out anything through the
unnaturally dense Haze he squinted and
turned on the high beams but the light
did nothing to cut through the fog
bouncing off of it like a billowing
curtain of white just as they passed the
sign the van began to slow rapidly its
engines sputtering and grinding as the
vehicle skidded to a sudden stop damn it
Dr bright thumped the steering wheel in
frustration any of you know how to fix a
car he looked at the team of operatives
in the back seat they all Shrugged
non-committally the only thing worse
than wandering into that fog would be
sitting in the broken down van watching
Tweedledum and tweedled Dumber try to
attend to the failing engine his private
joke almost lifted his mood but not
quite he popped open the door and
stepped out into the cold damp air well
I'll figure it out I'm gonna go look
around Dr bright shoved his hands into
his pockets and not knowing what might
wait on the other side began his walk
into silent hill with each step he
ruminated on the events that had gotten
him here where did those guys at the
foundation get off disciplining him like
an unruly child sure he liked his pranks
he enjoyed a good joke and maybe
sometimes he took it just a little bit
too far but he'd like to see them
confront the existential dread of
immortality without needing a humorous
Outlet every now and then they'd crack
under the pressure without a release of
some kind so what gave them the right to
put him a brilliant if unconventional
mind in some kind of glorified time out
he scoffed out loud to himself and the
sound echoed in the vacant streets the
sheer emptiness of it all snapped him
out of his self-pity and for the first
time he looked up to take in his
surroundings the stubborn fog refused to
dissipate no matter how how far he
walked but at least he could make out
the shape of the buildings now of parked
cars on the side of the road now parked
wrecked abandoned left to rust he
scanned the fog for human Silhouettes
listen for voices for any signs of life
but there was no one he approached a
building and found it dilapidated rotted
wood collapsing in on itself windows
cracked door boarded up tight the
buildings next to it looked very much
the same what the hell it was sent to
investigate recent disappearances but
this town looked as if its entire
population had vanished decades ago or
he thought with a small shutter all
decided to leave in a hurry what could
have driven them out okay that's it I'm
done Dr bright remarked turning a swift
180 degrees and preparing to go back the
way he came as he did he froze where
there had once been continuous unbroken
Road the street now ended in a jagged
edge a deep dark Chasm the only thing
that waited Beyond it was too broad to
jump across and he couldn't see another
road out of town hey guys he called out
hoping to draw the attention of one of
the men he had left with the van a
little help over here but no response
hello you shouted again louder this time
when no one answered he repeated himself
again and again with increasing
desperation his voice growing hoarse
from the effort had they somehow fixed
the van and left him there had they
fallen into the chasm where the road
once was and been killed on impact there
was no rational explanation for what was
at play here but as the consciousness of
a man living inside of an ancient amulet
reminded himself he verily rarely
encountered rational things in his life
there had to be a way out he just had to
find it if he can go back well he would
just have to keep moving forward on
through the winding Labyrinth of the
street through the Maze of crumbling
buildings looking for any signs of life
he followed a natural Bend in the road
and suddenly found himself wedged
between two buildings done a narrow
claustrophobic alley it seemed that this
place didn't feel much like playing by
the ordinary rules of time and space and
while Dr bright could usually appreciate
a rule breaker being a little rebellious
himself that uncertainty was putting him
on edge his breaths came in Shallow
gasps his chest tight with apprehension
as he turned in a circle looking for the
best way out he heard a sound behind him
the first noise he had heard other than
his own breathing in quite some time he
was the soft plotting sound of uneven
footsteps like someone small walking
with a limp he Whirled around to face
the noise and saw what he might have
mistaken for a child until he got a
proper look at it the thing that was
steadily approaching him was small and
humanoid in shape but that was where the
similarities to a human being ended its
skin was a pale modeled gray the shade
of a body fished out of a river after
weeks of bloating and Decay its mouth
was a twisted gaping hole more like a
wound than a mouth and in place of its
eyes were a pair of slits and the pale
flesh it stumbled as it walked like it
was still learning how but the childish
ineptitude did nothing to distract from
the creature's Menace as it Advanced
towards Dr Wright he saw the glint of
something metal and the creature's
gnarled fist it held a rusty knife as it
got closer it slashed haphazardly in his
Direction and its mouth opened wider to
let out a chilling high-pitched giggle
this thing was preparing to carve him up
and enjoy every second of the job as he
took in the sight of the horrible gray
child in front of him Dr bright had been
frozen to the spot unable to force his
legs to carry him away but the sight of
the knife the Grim realization of just
exactly what this thing had in store for
him shocked him back to life he grabbed
a wooden beam leading up against the
nearest wall and threw it at the little
monster knocking it onto its back it was
immobilized just long enough for Dr
bright to get his bearings turn and run
toward the wider Street as he did he
could hear the gleeful laughter as the
creature climbed back to its feet and it
only pushed him to run faster when he
could no longer hear the Little
Footsteps or the Warped Giggles of the
great child Dr right stopped to catch
his breath so it seemed like there was
still life in Silent Hill after all
there just wasn't human life there was
silence for a moment nothing but Dr
Wright's heart pounding in his head as
he bent over his knees and silently
cursed himself for not exercising this
body more often then the shrill Cry of
an air raid siren ripped through the
foggy air and for a moment his heart
stopped what the hell did that sound
mean he stood up inspecting his
surroundings for signs of danger for
what a tornado a bomb he wasn't sure but
nothing could have prepared him for what
he saw next the entire landscape had
shifted around him in an instant he was
unsure of how exactly to describe it
except to say that this world had gotten
darker more dangerous where the streets
had been lit by dim gray sunlight
filtered through the haze there was now
Darkness say for an occasional Street
Lamp with a flickering red bulb he
couldn't be sure if it was a trick of
the light but he could swear there was
blood staining the street smeared across
the brick walls of buildings on either
side the town had been ominous before
but now it was like something out of a
nightmare and all the while the siren
continued to blare warning of a danger
he could not see he needed to find
shelter that was it from what he didn't
know but whatever was coming could not
be good Dr bright ran to the nearest
door twisting the knob trying to yank it
open but it wouldn't bind the hinges
were rusted shut and there was no time
to try and force them open he tried
another door and another and another it
was as if the house is new to try and
keep him out to keep him exposed and
vulnerable on the outside finally he
reached a two-story house with peeling
white paint and a mahogany door one that
looks so familiar but that he couldn't
quite place when he turned the knob the
door creaked open with ease and he
quickly raced inside slamming the door
shut behind him and locked it as Dr
bright slumped against the door
overtaken with exhaustion an intrusive
thought made his stomach drop was he
alone in this house had he really found
shelter or had he just shut himself
inside with something even worse than
what waited out there in the silence he
could swear he heard the quiet thumping
of a pulse but he couldn't tell if it
was his own or the houses beating heart
he couldn't just stay here dreaming up
all the horrors that might be waiting he
needed to gather data investigate his
surroundings and come up with potential
Solutions he needed to be a scientist on
unsteady legs Dr bright began to walk
the halls of the house taking in his
surroundings properly for the first time
it was Dusty and dark a place left
vacant for quite some time but there
were signs of a life once lived within
the House's walls a rocking horse in the
corner a Shelf full of well-worn books
the title is scratched and itch in his
brain memories he hadn't touched in
decades strange that so many of the
books in this house would remind him of
the pages he once flipped through
staying inside to read while his brother
played in the yard outside his brother
Dr bright swallowed the lump in his
throat at the thought of TJ no use going
down that path not right now he
continued his walk through the house
taking in the cobwebs the couch covered
with plastic the coffee table and the TV
set along the hall leading to the
bathroom there were rows of family
pictures hanging in neat little frames
he stopped to take a look wondering what
sort of family had once lived here as
his eyes fell on the first photograph
his blood turned to ice in his veins a
boy looked out from within the frame a
familiar boy with a mop of red hair a
freckled nose and kind smiling eyes now
Dr bright whispered to himself but there
was no denying it it was TJ his brother
somehow looking at him from inside a
photograph in an abandoned house in
Silent Hill next there was a photo of TJ
and an older man Dr Bright's stomach
turned their father every photograph was
of his family the family he would never
know again not the way they were and
there in one photo in the middle TJ and
his father were joined by another figure
one with the face scratched out of the
picture he knew though he couldn't see
for certain that it was him removed from
the family photo by force but the bond
between them All Forever broken TJ's
eyes and the picture seemed to be filled
with tears heartbroken his father
glowered out of the frame at him pure
hatred in his gaze he couldn't look any
more and turned away on the opposite
wall another photograph of TJ was
waiting Dr bright fell while rising in
his throat he recognized the photo he
saw it sometimes when he closed his eyes
at night was a picture taken with
scp-978 the desired camera the anomalous
camera that reveals its subject's
innermost Desires in the photo TJ's
hands were pressed to the lens like an
animal clawing at the boundaries of its
cage his eyes were filled with tears
spilling over and streaming down his
cheeks and his mouth was wide open in an
endless scream of fear and Agony this Dr
Wright knew was the wordless scream
inside his brother's mind at all times
after so much testing with the
foundation had destroyed him
he whispered to the picture I did what I
could do I did what I could to take the
pain away he trailed off the words dying
in his throat as the sound of a heavy
rattling breath came from the room at
the end of the hall it was a thick
wheezing sound like a death rattle a
dozen times over he didn't want to see
what was making the noise but as if in a
trance he found his feet carrying him
towards it he crossed the threshold of
what should have been in the kitchen but
instead found himself in the dimly lit
Hospital the air smelled the
formaldehyde and dried vomit the steady
beep of a heart monitor joining the
chorus of heavy agonizing breathing at
the end of the Long Haul there was one
single room the door standing slightly
ajar with slow agonizing steps Dr bright
approached the room the breathing grew
louder and louder the beep of the heart
monitor almost deafening in his ears he
could barely separate the strange
breathing from his own finding his
breaths coming in time with the painful
rattling sound he pushed the door open
and saw a figure lying in a hospital bed
it was once human but it could only be
described now as a conglomerate of
disease and pain on top of the figure's
head thinning in patches but still
recognizable was a log of red hair no TJ
no Dr Bright's voice broke off in a sob
at the sight the thing that was once his
brother turned seeking the sound of his
voice though he could not see isn't this
what you wanted a low voice rumbled
behind him Dr bright Whirled around to
see a dark shadow red eyes glowing in
the low light it moved like a wisp of
black smoke but he knew that voice well
enough to tell him just who it was his
father you let them do this to him I I
didn't I didn't mean for this to happen
Dr bright stammered you didn't care the
demon father roared and the light bulb
above their heads flared and burst
sending shards of glass scattering
everywhere all he ever did was help
people to heal pain and all you ever did
was cause it Dr bright found the
strength to move running through the
doorway sending the shape of his father
in every direction as the smell of
sulfur and blood filled his nose I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry he wept as he
ran hearing his father's agonized cries
his brothers labored breathing as he
tore back down the hospital Hall as he
did hands began to reach through the
walls the floor the ceiling they were
Rotting Flesh gone green and stiff arms
followed the hands then shoulders then
faces he recognized d-class uniforms lab
coats face after familiar face everyone
who had ever worn The Amulet he realized
with a sudden wave of nausea everyone
whose body he had taken who he had
killed so that he could live this is
what you do he could hear his father's
voice just behind him the curls black
smoke nipping at his heels what kind of
creature kills to live something that
deserves to die but you can't can you
you're a parasite sucking all the good
in the life from this world until it's
an empty husk just like you the living
graveyard of victims reach for Dr bright
tearing at his clothes as he passed them
there were so many you never realized
how many until he saw them all lined up
like this I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm so
sorry he said to every face he passed
but there was no forgiveness in their
dead eyes his father's voice fell silent
but there was no reprieve instead there
was the sound of heavy footsteps
pursuing him the grating shriek of a
large bladed weapon dragging along the
ground Dr bright glanced over his
shoulder and saw a massive hulking
figure like a man but with a jagged
metal pyramid covering his head he was
clad in blood-stained clothing and
approaching Dr Bryant with a casual
Menace of some something that had killed
endless times before and was ready to do
it again it didn't care to chase him it
knew it would eventually catch up as he
looked at the figure it began to warp to
it morphed into something else something
he recognized a man with black hair and
gray eyes that revealed nothing but cold
malice a body covered in tattoos of the
Arcane and the Occult of merciless
grinning faces belonging to ancient
monsters and in his hand a long-bladed
weapon a curved soared perfectly
engineered for battle it was impossible
he should be contained but there he was
scp-076-2 looking at Dr bright the same
way he had on the day he had first worn
The Amulet the day he became an
Abomination the sound of his brother's
breathing grew louder his father's voice
bellowing in his mind and he felt the
grasp of the Fallen Foundation employees
at his back it was all too much too many
reminders of every failure every hurt Dr
bride collapsed to his knees and bared
his neck to Able in submission you're
right I I should be punished I've done
nothing but hurt and kill and destroy
everything I touch just punish me please
I'm begging you then something Dr bright
never could have expected the figure
that looked like Abel but couldn't be
began to laugh a cruel Hollow sound
no it said in a voice that sounded like
a chorus of hundreds we will release you
nothing we can do here will ever be
worse worse than the eternity of Torment
that stretches before you good luck to
you Dr bright Jack Bright let out a
whale of Agony reaching out to Abel with
pleading hands as the entity turned and
slowly walked away leaving him there
alone with the hell that was his
thoughts then everything faded to Black
Dr bright Dr bright the sound of one of
his team members brought Dr Wright back
to Consciousness and he opened his eyes
he was lying on the side of the same
road he had walked along before right
next to the sign welcoming the group to
Silent Hill you're all still here he
asked weekly what do you mean the man
looked puzzled he parked the van you got
out you fell down and we've been trying
to wake you up how long was I out Dr
Bright's Vision swam as he tried to wrap
his mind around the information I don't
know about 10 minutes
scp-096 the shy guy woke up in an
unfamiliar room without a thought in its
head however one thing quickly occurred
to it the this was not its containment
chamber no the solid steel Cube that had
kept it locked up for decades now didn't
have a front desk or walls covered in
strange child-like murals or tinny party
music playing over old speakers wherever
scp-096 had found itself it certainly
wasn't the place it had come to call
home if it could read it would have
registered the words behind the front
desk painted onto the wall bambans
kindergarten where Joy Comes Alive
little did 096 know something really did
come to life here at bamban's
kindergarten but it definitely wasn't
Joy
scp-096 was typically used to a much
more confined space so presented with so
much strange Freedom its natural
instinct was to wander around whimpering
quietly to itself this place was
certainly peculiar with multiple large
reinforced doors each one having a large
red button fixed to the wall above them
a strange green creature was painted on
the wall within a fixed speech bubble
that read jumbo Josh says eat fruits and
vegetables if you want to be strong like
me though 096 paid no mind to such
things this place looked like an SCP
Foundation containment facility mixed
with an off-brand Chuck E cheese and
some tiny part of the Shy Guy's dim and
dismal brain wanted to see more of it
what other Secrets could it hold the shy
guy pressed one of the big red buttons
causing the doors to open underneath it
there was a faint sound of childish
laughter somewhere down the distant Hall
how had it ever found its way into such
a strange place the deeper the shy guy
wandered the more strange murals it saw
on the wall there was one for a large
orange cartoon jellyfish with one
staring eye where the speech bubble red
Stinger Flynn says having many arms
allows me to help a lot of people then a
squat blue gorilla like creature with
sharp lower teeth had a speech bubble
that read Captain fiddles says
a white feminine cat-like creature had
the speech bubble vanbelina says
kindness is free so sprinkle it
everywhere a misshapen pink bird
creature had the speech bubble opila
bird says laughter is the best medicine
so make sure to smile and of course most
importantly of all presiding over the
creativity room was a mural of a
grinning red creature wearing a pair of
party hats on its head like horns his
speech bubble read banban says sharing
is caring your pancreas is mine a
whiteboard not far from this mural had
the words run for your lives hastily
scrawled onto it to anyone but the shy
guy who had no point of reference this
was clearly not a normal kindergarten as
the shy guy passed into the hallway
slowly lumbering along it suddenly felt
an intense Spike of burning pain right
through its forehead Rising like a fever
pitch the shy guy subdued whimpers
quickly escalated into horrifying whales
of animalistic rage this could only mean
one thing somewhere something had made
the terrible mistake of gazing at the
shy guy's face in fact not 10 feet away
the unfortunate opala bird had made that
very mistake it typically peeked out
from behind one of the hallways pillars
to get a good look at any potential
Intruders or new prey wandering into its
midst but this time the beastly Birds
curiosity had taken it from Predator to
prey itself though it wouldn't realize
this until it was already too late as
the mutant bird creature skittered back
into the cavernous Hall filled with
plastic trees and an underwhelming play
area the shy guy came Galloping after it
on all fours roaring with Fury the opala
bird was shocked to see the creature
giving chase this doesn't make sense I
meant to is you you're not meant to
chase me but things are rarely fair when
it comes to the shy guy arguably one of
the most dangerous euclid-class
creatures ever kept in Foundation
containment the oppola bird flapped
desperately towards the boarded-up
escape hatch but the shy guy was so much
faster he grabbed hold that the bird
gripping it in its iron clutches and
began to stretch open its bottom jaw
with a blood curdling Roar we'll spare
you the details of what happened next
but suffice to say little more than a
handful of feathers were loud after
finishing off the opela bird the shy guy
reverted from Rage back to pitiful
sadness this place was no better than
the SCP Foundation there were still
creatures here to look at its face and
drive it into a state of extreme
emotional distress it was horrible the
shy guy needed to find a way to hide
himself away again so he decided to tear
away the planks covering up the escape
hatch and looked down the narrow Hall
and there the shy guy actually found
something to its liking two platforms
one on either side of the room with what
seemed to be a deep dark Chasm between
the two for most there was an electrical
lift system for carrying them between
the platforms but the shy guy had no
interest in the platforms he only saw
the darkness below where nobody could
see his face that would suit him just
fine the shy guy jumped over the
guardrail and plummeted down below into
the dark feeling the air against its
cold gray skin as it fell felt wonderful
I dared to think that it might even find
solace in this deep dark place but as
soon as he hid something solid some kind
of metal lift system alarms went off and
flashing red lights soon made everything
down there in the darkness visible to be
exposed like this while it thought it
was hidden was the dreaded Shy Guy's
worst nightmare little did he know he
would soon become the worst nightmare of
a number of other beasts as the shy guy
crawled off the metal platform hoping
that perhaps it could find another place
to hide down here its hands and feet
splashed into shallow water had
something sprung a leak down here the
shy guy began wandering the half dark as
the water of this flooded sub-basement
area pooled around him it had no idea
that another creature was already
sneaking up behind it getting ready to
strike before 096 could even react
several whipped-like orange tentacles
wrapped around its Limbs and began
delivering an antagonizing shock through
its body more tentacles came in soon
after wrapping around the Shy Guy's body
and face delivering shock After Shock
After Shock with its millions of tiny
venomous Stinger barbs for a second it
seemed like the surprise attack might
actually be able to subdue the monster
but little did the Shy Guy's attacker
the Monstrous real Stinger Flynn know
that attacking it was just another way
to activate its Infamous rage State the
second that Stinger Flynn relented even
just for a moment the shy guy grabbed
him by the tentacles and slammed him
into the watery floor again and again
and again until the grip of his
tentacles loosened around the Shy Guy's
body and he was defenseless with stinger
panicked and immobilized the shy guy
released the full force of his
Supernatural Fury striking the Demonic
jellyfish with his fists until what was
left couldn't be distinguished from the
water it used to be floating in Stinger
Flynn had been completely annihilated
the shy guy once again temporarily
returned to a state of calm and wandered
out of this watery basement into a
nearby hallway where everything was
bright and dry the walls were painted in
garish childlike drawings of a jungle
with janky looking animals the shy guy
paid no mind to any of it all he wanted
was to find somewhere that he could
actually be alone and away from prying
eyes of all these freaks this dream was
short-lived because as soon as the shy
guy found new room a wide open
Auditorium filled with inflatable jungle
trees like a crude play area he was
being stalked yet again a powerful
muscular Predator with veins stretching
over its bulging muscles and blue skin
it knew that this Intruder had already
killed two of its fellow Garden dwellers
but this time it would put the spindly
pale Stranger in its place the Shanghai
heard something rumbling towards it from
behind and turned upon hearing the
blood-curdling war cry of ooga booga
boogauga it was the gorilla-like captain
fiddles with strands of saliva hanging
from his tusks he leaped onto the Shy
Guy and began pounding into its hideous
face with this huge blue fists Captain
fiddles would destroy the shy guy pound
him into the concrete until he stopped
moving the one thing that Captain
fiddles didn't expect was for the shy
guy to start fighting back and he was
about to learn the hard truth that the
shy guy could fight a lot harder than
him the SCP is spindly but immensely
powerful arms grabbed Captain fiddles by
the shoulders and threw him into the
wall causing huge cracks to crawl up
towards the ceiling before Captain
fiddles could even think about wrenching
himself free the shy guy leaped to his
feet and bounded over to him the shy guy
grabbed Captain fiddles by the ankles
and ripped him out of the wall letting
his body drop to the floor and then
unleashing hell upon Him Captain fiddles
would have begged for mercy if he wasn't
already dead before the shy guy could
even begin to calm down a trapdoor
opened in the floor beneath him dropping
him into a new area a multi-colored maze
where 096 was trapped like a helpless
rat with the body count of an atomic
bomb once again the shy guy didn't need
to go looking for trouble because
trouble was already on its way the Pure
White cat-like Ben bellina pounced from
a sharp corner in the Maze claws barred
she jumped onto the shy guy latching
onto him and clawing trying to scratch
his nightmare face if the shine guy had
ever possessed anything resembling
patience it would have run out long
before now he grabbed vanbelina
shrugging off the pain of her claws and
tossing her into the darkness high above
she flew off with a cat-like yell and
hit some distant ceiling with a crunch
suffice to say she wouldn't be back to
bother the shy guy again tired and angry
the pale Abomination didn't feel like
wandering through a maze instead it just
charged straight through destroying a
colorful wall after colorful wall when
it encountered whatever was behind this
extremely frustrating afternoon it would
destroy it with extreme prejudice that
was almost certainty after breaking
through one more wall the shy guy
tumbled out into a strange room where a
grinning red creature was waiting for
him wearing two party hats on top of his
head this was no mere Lackey it was Bam
Bam himself the one behind this
nightmarish kindergarten he stared right
into the shy guys face with no fear at
all almost like he knew something that
the shy guy didn't and it was true he
had no plan to fight the shy guy himself
he'd brought a champion with him as the
shy guy started to scream and rage all
the boxes behind Bam Bam tumbled out of
the way as a huge figure Rose a behemoth
at least 50 feet tall with green skin
giant teeth and huge staring eyes it was
jumbo Josh and if the shy guy wanted to
graduate from this nightmare
kindergarten it would need to defeat him
and Bam Bam the shy guy growled digging
its claws into the ground and preparing
to charge forward challenge
accepted did you hear that not so long
ago a five-year-old boy went up against
12 of Russia's greatest chess Grand
Masters and do you know what happened he
lost every single match that's because
winning a chest dear viewers isn't easy
chess is an ancient game of strategy
cunning and skill it's not just about
thinking one step ahead of your opponent
that's not going to be enough make a
wrong prediction and you could end up
sacrificing one of your pieces as well
as vital space on the board but thinking
two to three steps ahead beating your
adversary's moves before they've even
been made now there's a viable strategy
tricky but viable after all if it was
easy we'd all be queen scambit level
chess prodigies Eric Matthews had never
been good at the game but he had a
pretty substantial reason to keep trying
and that reason's name was Brian
Matthews his father you see for as long
as Eric could remember his dad had
regarded high level of skill on the
chessboard to be a sign of intellectual
superiority intelligence was something
that Brian put quite a considerable
value on given that he was a professor
at a university in their home country of
England some of Eric's earliest memories
were of playing chess with his dad
usually on a Friday night when Brian got
home after a week of giving lectures to
the next generation of Scholars
obviously with his son at such a young
age the professor would take it easy on
Eric playing in a much laxer fashion
focusing instead on teaching the boy the
basics of the game and for a time at
least it was good it was a rare time
that Eric and his academic father could
spend bonding after all with his mother
gone his dad was all he had but as the
years passed the game Changed by the
time Eric was a teenager Brian had
stopped pulling his punches on the
chessboard he hoped his son would build
on what he'd learned when they played in
the past using those skills to best his
dad on the board but to Eric playing
chess had never been about a purely
educational experience it was more about
spending time with his old man Time
After Time the young man's pawns fell
prey to Brian's expertly considered and
far more competitive moves try as he
might Eric couldn't best his dad he
tried his best and never stopped putting
the effort into every game but thinking
too hard about one possible plan of
attack left him wide open to a
counter-strategy from the professor over
and over again he landed himself in
Checkmate or made illegal moves without
even realizing it every time earning
criticism and chastise men from his
scholarly father every game it got worse
it was like Eric could feel his father's
gaze and the weighty expectations behind
it with each move he made across the
board there were so many nights where he
wondered if it would be better to give
up entirely to knock down his own King
and concede but how could he ever find
any other shared interests with his dad
Beyond the two of them playing chess it
had become a Lifeline tethering Father
and Son together and to cut it now left
Eric uncertain if he'd sink or be able
to swim alongside Brian he had long
admired his father his achievements in
Academia were impossible to avoid with
more frames certificates hung up on the
walls than there were photos of the pair
of them together but the shadow would
cast over him made Eric desperate to
keep this one shred of Common Ground
alive Eric wasn't the type to give up
despite how much of an uphill struggled
the situation felt like taking a leaf
out of his Professor father's scholarly
ways he decided to learn the game inside
and out every known move and strategy he
would research the entire history of
Chess itself if that's what it took to
play with the same skill as his dear old
dad over the coming weeks Eric checked
out every book at his local library on
the subject beginner's guides Advanced
rule books and even a few volumes on
notable players throughout the
extensively long history of the game
along the way a chapter of a certain
book stood out to Eric it described a
chess Prodigy from Russia who had
created an early mechanical chest device
known as the samurai it had been
designed to be a traveling curiosity and
would sit playing chess games against
volunteers taken from a spectating
audience each one of them having forked
over some of their hard-earned money to
watch this man-made wonder the Russian
chess Prodigy's young daughters also had
a love for the game seeing that gave
Eric a Pang of jealousy wondering if
those daughters had as much trouble
playing their own father as he did with
Brian but at least there was an
underlying shred of Hope there too if
this father and his daughters could bond
over chess maybe there was a chance for
Eric and his dad too sadly it's one
thing to try and learn all the facts you
can about Chess it's an entirely
different Beast to put all that
information to use and apply it to an
actual game despite quite having read
every book he could get his hands on
Eric still couldn't best Brian at the
board it was like nothing had changed
his father barely noticed when Eric
tried to replicate movesets he'd read up
on and still managed to not only counter
those moves but check his Queen in the
process so practice Eric thought after
all practice was supposedly meant to
make perfect right the plan was simple
if he practices chess moves enough times
and figure out how he could call on what
he'd learned then he might stand a
chance at winning when he and his dad
played each other there was just one
hiccup to this plan Eric needed someone
to practice against the only other
person in the house was Brian meaning it
was that hiccup that turned into a
problem almost big enough to stop Eric
in his tracks that is until he went into
his father's lab it was under the house
itself a sort of sub-level maybe used as
a basement or seller by the previous
owners but since Professor Matthews and
his son had lived there the entire room
had been remodeled into an at-home
laboratory not a terribly Advanced one
of course this was the early 90s after
all majority of Brian's time even when
he was at home instead of working at the
University was spent on his own
downstairs in the lab Eric had gone down
there in search of his dad to ask him if
there was anyone whom he knew who he
could practice and develop his chess
skills with but instead what he found
down there was the last thing he
expected to see not that he had any clue
exactly what it was at first the thing
was some kind of bizarre Contraption a
collection of components that didn't
seem to be in any logical configuration
however it was primarily composed of
something that Eric recognized All Too
Well a chess table this one was metal
steel to be precise and seemed to be
hooked up to some sort of computer well
back in the 90s computers were hardly as
commonplace as they are now Erica came
in a fair few at school and the library
although this one was different it
seemed old far older than Eric thought
computers had been around for as far as
he knew they'd only really come to
prominence in the mid 80s but this
computer looked like it predated even
that period noticing another part of the
contraption a large steam engine with
the words manufactured by mods lay sons
and field established 1840 engraved on
one side made it seem that this whole
device had been around since the
Victorian era the next part that caught
his eyes was the chess pieces themselves
each one standing neatly in its place on
the board they looked delicate
intricately carved from some smooth
substance for a moment Eric toyed with
the thought of how they could even be
made from bone noticing how each Pond
Knight Rook Bishop king and queen were
all about the size of a human finger
bone he dismissed the idea nobody would
ever do something like that oh
Eric grabbed a sheet covering a large
component hooked up to the mess lifting
it away in a swift pole it unveiled what
was sitting beneath a full Suite of 18th
century Samurai armor Eric to look
closer at the embellishments on the
surface of the pauldrons he was no
expert on feudal Japan but it looked
authentic enough to be the real thing if
not a very close approximation taking a
look at the collection of oddities all
tethered together in his father's lab a
certain detail of all his chest research
came to the Forefront of Eric's mind the
armor that had given it away this was
the samurai or at the very least a crude
homemade version of it that his dad had
put together but if it worked it was
also something to practice against it
didn't take Eric long to start tinkering
with the contraption trying to get it to
work all the while the question of why
his dad owns such a thing kept drumming
up noise in the back of his head had
Brian built it or was this the original
made by that Rush chess Prodigy was this
machine the reason that Eric's dad
possessed such an unbeatable skill at
chess would using it give him the edge
he needed to best him at the game and
earn his father's respect after what
felt like hours upon hours of trial and
error with a machine he could barely
comprehend Eric seemed to have cracked
it as far as he could tell the steam
engine powered the whole Contraption and
could be set to five different speeds
labeled on the side in Roman numerals
the power from the engine was then fed
to some kind of sophisticated mechanism
that was within the suit of Samurai
armor allowing it to move in what
appeared to be a series of
electromagnets that moved the chess
pieces and kept them on the board
flicking it onto the third highest of
the five speed levels the machine word
into life the sound of creaking and
grinding of metal filled the lab
kneeling opposite Eric went to make the
first move only to stop himself it
wasn't that he changed his mind about
practicing against Samurai but because
of the speed he'd set it to determining
that the settings might have correlated
to difficulty levels Eric figured that
if he really wanted to get the most
rigorous practice to really hone his
chest moves he needed to commit fully
reaching for the dial he turned the
device up to its Fifth and highest speed
then made his first move he pushed one
of the bone-colored prawns forward by a
single square and waited a split second
passed and the arm of the early
automaton responded with its first
counter move it was quick almost moving
with the same natural fluidity and speed
as an actual human being albeit still
with a little bit of creaking and some
slight Clockwork like stutters but it
worked nonetheless the machine could
play the tension over the first game was
palpable forming a layer of sweat over
Eric's forehead everywhere and tick of
the machine gave the impression that
they were playing with a stop clock
timing each of their moves adding to the
urgency despite this Eric Matthews tried
his best stay calm this was practice
after all a dry run not the inevitable
game he'd play against his dad with
every move he made his heart drummed
against his ribs uncertain he'd made the
right call each time the robotic hand
cruelly knocked over one of his Pieces
away Eric felt a surge of frustration
but told himself to quell it he kept
focused using what he'd researched to
adapt and respond accordingly to each of
the machine's moves until Checkmate he'd
beaten it he might have lost everything
saved for a night a rook his king and
queen but he had won trapped without
anywhere else to move on the board the
middle finger of the automaton conceded
the Game knocking over its own King and
resignation panting heart racing from
the sheer excitement of being on The
Winning Side of A game Eric Hurley
gathered up and reset all the pieces he
had to go again not just so that he
could be certain it wasn't a fluke but
to make sure he had what it took to take
on his Professor father back and forth
Eric went with the chess machine over
and over again they were fairly evenly
matched it seemed Eric won the second
game only to be best on the next two but
it was sometime afterward he had lost
count of exactly how many rounds later
but things started to change maybe it
was the age and condition of the
Victorian era chess computer the natural
wear and tear stopping it from
functioning properly But Eric noticed
that the samurai started to make moves
that were illogical that practically
offered him the upper hand with no
discernible strategy behind them then
its movements became flat out illegal
disregarding the directions and number
of squares each different piece was
allowed to move before long it was
moving them erratically around the
chessboard refusing to cooperate and
forcing Eric to call an end to the days
practicing unfortunately it wouldn't be
the end of the unusual things that would
happen that day did you send me that
weird email was the first question
Eric's dad asked him when he returned
home looking noticeably under the
weather confused Eric said that he had
no idea what his father was talking
about Professor Matthews then went on to
describe what he'd received on his work
computer it had been an email with a
file attached to it named shakhmedi a
word in Russian that translates to chess
embedded in the email below although it
had taken a long time to load being
opened on a 1990s computer there had
apparently been a photo as well it was
rather odd Eric Brian went on right
unnerving to tell the truth black and
white all sort of distorted and
stretched but it looked like two young
girls one grinning and the other
screaming I've been feeling well not
quite myself since I saw it with that
Brian excused himself stating that he'd
been suffering from headaches in a high
temperature and as a result needed to go
and lay down it wasn't like his father
to get ill Eric thought but of course he
had no reason to assume it was anything
serious probably just a speed to fatigue
after a long day of teaching at the
University no cause for concern if only
that's all it was within a few hours
Brian was completely restless so unable
to sleep that simply taking a nap was
impossible he kept calling to Eric
complaining of the sound of childlike
laughter coming from somewhere in the
house but his son hadn't heard anything
by the time the sun went down Eric was
trying to calm his dad down through a
rush of intense anxiety that gripped him
Ryan had been claimed to be
hallucinating seeing the Warped faces of
two girls that frightened him half to
death it was getting late long past the
time that they usually played chess
together but for now Eric's mind was
focused solely on helping his dad for
while he seemed to be able to calm his
father down only to realize Brian wasn't
settled at all he was awake eyes open
fully conscious but wasn't responding at
all to Eric asking if he was all right
instead the accomplished academic just
stared blankly into space Eric had been
up all night exhausted worried for
Brian's safety and completely clueless
about what was happening to him after a
while being non-responsive his dad
seemed to regain a little bit of
Lucidity once more but his behavior was
erratic take me back to work I I need to
get on my computer Brian demanded of his
son when Eric refused that's when his
dad got angry and agitated Professor
Brian Matthews was sadly found dead
within the next few months several
months later as the sole executor of his
father's estate and last living relative
Eric had to be the one to go through his
dad's personal belongings volumes upon
volumes of thick academic books his
smart scholarly clothes the house was
almost clear now save for one thing that
was left in the basement lab flicking on
the light switch Eric looked at the
samurai sitting motionless still
uncovered after their last practice game
he'd sold off the chess pieces to a
collector in New York now it was just an
empty Oddity Eric placed a king on the
board board one of the ones that he and
his dad had used when they played each
other with a gentle flick of his finger
he toppled it resigning to the strange
automaton and leaving it there in the
laboratory he wasn't sure how but he had
some kind of gut feeling that this chess
machine had somehow been responsible for
his father's fate of course Eric had no
idea what the device actually was and
what or who lay beneath its worrying
metal Parts
scp-1875 is the designation given to
this machine now and has been ever since
the foundation recovered it not long
after Eric sold his father's house they
are able to learn much more about it
than young Mr Matthews or even the late
professor Matthews ever had not just how
to make it work or what its function was
but who had built it and who had been
used to build it although details of his
real name eluded the foundation's top
researchers they were able to uncover
newspaper articles about the device from
all over Russia America and England
dating back to the early 1990s the
Russian chess Prodigy who'd invented it
and toured the chess playing machine
around had used some interesting
components to make his automaton maybe
they were what derived its skill at the
game and its apparent temperament when
the device was made to play at maximum
speed for too long he had used his
daughters to make the machine deep
within the heart of this early form of
computer the two girls brain tissue had
been hooked up to the electromagnets the
machined moves were theirs each Pawn or
Rook shifting across the black and white
squares of the board every rule or
strategy their Prodigy father had taught
it all determined how the device played
their minds taken from their skulls were
now the analytical engine of their
father's creation the bones of their
fingers he'd carved into chess pieces
over the coming weeks the foundation
naturally ran their usual slew of tests
on
scp-1875 playing multiple games of Chess
against it every time they increase the
machine's five levels of speed until it
started behaving erratically while on
the highest setting shortly after every
member of personnel working on scp-1875
received a bizarre email it contained a
file named with the Russian word for
chess and a photograph of the stretched
distorted smiling and screaming faces of
two young girls faces that you might be
seeing very soon you all know exactly
who I am the bald chemistry teacher
looked around at the men surrounding him
in the desert Cadillacs leather jackets
blacked out Shades the gang members
shifted nervously from foot to foot as
the man bragged openly about what he's
done to build his criminal Empire Walter
White's attention turned back to the men
in front of him a slight sneer played
around his lips now say my name the man
took a moment to reply as the desert
desert wind blew behind him he seemed to
be weighing his options realizing
quickly that he had lost all control
over the situation you're you're
Heisenberg your gut bang Walter White
fell to the ground dead the characters
all around yelped in Surprise Drew their
guns and started wildly pointing them
around the circle trying to figure out
who killed the great Heisenberg but his
killer just stared in awe from his couch
in the front room as the Netflix show
kept playing on the TV had the toy gun
in his hand really done that Josh had
admitted to himself that he had a
problem a long time ago but at least
being a yard sale addict was cheaper
than just a regular old retail addict
actually in truth he was also an estate
sale addict a garage sale addict and a
thrift store addict anywhere you could
buy people's old junk for rock bottom
prices he would sniff it out the
Saturday that his life changed forever
was just like any other Saturday really
in the sweaty heat of the Atlantic City
suburbs he hadn't meant to stop by any
sales today but one just so happened to
catch his eye there was a box marked
nerd stuff and he took that as a
personal challenge was this some old
lady's version of nerd stuff or a
veteran dungeon Masters Treasure Trove
the reality was somewhere in between the
two there were a couple of seasons of
Buffy on VHS a copy of the original Deus
Ex and some Legend of Zelda plushies it
hadn't really been worth stopping his
car for except for a little plastic
splash of color that caught his eye Josh
reached way down to the bottom of the
box and rooted around for it there was
no way it couldn't possibly be the toy
he'd spent all his childhood asking for
and never getting but in fact it was a
1985 Nintendo Entertainment System
zapper with an orange grip and Barrel
NES gray Bodywork and the Beautiful font
printed along the side it was
unmistakable he threw a wad of cash at
the old lady behind the table and rushed
back into his car quickly as he could it
was time to cancel his Day plans he had
a childhood dream to fulfill but no
sooner that he had got home and flipped
on his TV the dream Came Crashing Down
around him his old NES the one he'd had
since he was a little kid had sadly
keeled over it refused to power on no
matter what he did so that made his
zapper pretty much useless the best he
could do with it now would be to point
it at the TV and make pew pew noises
with his mouth so Josh opened up Netflix
and put on an episode of Breaking Bad
little did he know as he raised the
zapper to the screen that he was
actually in possession of
scp-674 nobody would know looking at it
on the surface even the most hardcore
Gamers wouldn't have a clue because you
can fully disassemble clean and
reassemble the zapper and get no
indication that it's anything other than
what it appears to be however as soon as
the gun is pointed at television screen
or a computer monitor of any kind it
starts to pose a very real threat or at
least a very real fictional threat if
you shoot at the screen whatever media
is playing on it at the time will react
and adapt to what has just happened that
means characters on the screens will
react in accordance with the rules of
their respective universes in a grounded
realistic drama The Gunshot will behave
like any other killing or wounding the
victim with perhaps enough time for them
to give a dying monologue but in an
episode of Rick and Morty the shot could
manifest in any number of bizarre and
creative ways news crews that witnessed
the user shooting a person in their live
report will continue to cover the
incident as if it is part of the ongoing
story if you shoot Walter White he falls
to the ground dead Josh stared at the
screen in utter amazement he didn't
expect the writers to kill off their
main character just like that wasn't
there supposed to be another 9 episodes
what would they do to fill all that time
as the episode played out it seemed to
mostly just follow Jesse trying
desperately to escape with his money
before it was too late he kept glancing
towards the camera for some reason with
a slight look of fear in his eyes very
strange creative decision there Josh
backed out of the show to scroll through
his continue watching there was
something a little creepy about how he'd
pointed the zapper at the TV pulled the
trigger and perfectly at that moment a
character had been shot time to pick out
another show without any guns and murder
for a bit you know something safe The
Familiar melodica tune filled the lounge
as various shots of Dunder Mifflin
employees busied themselves shredding
credit cards and answering phone calls
it never ceased to make his worries go
away seeing the words the office appear
on the screen he settled into the couch
watching as the characters all gathered
in the conference room for some first
aid training the CPR dummy lay on the
floor with Michael Scott earnestly
explaining to the woman that the victim
appeared to have lost their items he
laughed along as the scene descended
into chaos as none of the employees took
the training seriously at all even
though he'd seen this episode countless
times it never got old absent-mindedly
he pointed the gun at the TV and pulled
the trigger bang Pam collapsed on the
ground all the characters Dove out of
the way trying to find cover behind
their chairs not daring to peek out at
the camera only the first aid ladies
stayed on the scene trying her best to
resuscitate Pam it cut to a shot of
Dwight talking to the camera sadly he
said that it was almost funny but there
was a real heaviness in the moment his
eyes were red like he'd been crying off
camera Josh flipped the TV off and
stared at himself in the dark reflection
was he dreaming he hadn't just done that
Hattie fortunately for Josh and for the
rest of humanity he had not killed Jenna
frischer or Bryan Cranston he hadn't
even killed their characters in the
shows at least not for anyone other than
himself Reese search into scp-674 shows
that the appearance of characters being
killed off on screen only exists in the
mind of the shooter for everyone else
the office Remains the Same as it always
was unfortunately for Josh however Pam
is now dead in that universe and will
always be whenever he watches an episode
it leaves a real Shadow over the later
Seasons but the characters apparently
managed to do a good job pivoting into
its new darker tone other shows that
have been tested in research conditions
have yielded interesting results like in
Star Trek it is impossible to actually
kill Captain Kirk instead various red
shirts always just so happen to dive in
front of him or fall into frame at the
pivotal moment with a small Dead Zone on
the right hand side of the screen
characters who witness enough shootings
have the sense to stick to that side of
the frame whenever the shot is on them
sometimes going so far as to plead
directly with a viewer breaking the
fourth wall in their desperation to
survive when Josh came back from a long
walk outside he'd convinced himself that
what he had seen earlier was all just
some vivid dream a dream he didn't
remember waking up from but definitely
wasn't happening anymore he'd play some
video games that's what he would do he
had decided he would just play some
Super Smash Bros and unwind anyone who
has ever said that sentence to
themselves will know firsthand how
foolish that is not 10 minutes later
Josh had definitely forgotten all about
his dream from before he was too busy
raging and cursing at the screen he
couldn't stand playing against King
dididi that stupid Hammer move always
got him without thinking Josh snatched
the zapper from the couch next to him
and blasted to DD right in the face in
classic Smash Bros style the giant
penguin King was launched backwards
flying off the screen in a blast of
colorful smoke but he didn't respawn for
a second his character just stood on the
screen awkwardly before it kicked him
back out to the character select screen
this time though King did edi's picture
was Miss saying Josh couldn't help
himself he set up a free-for-all match
straight away picking all the characters
he hated to fight against Sonic Mario
Pikachu Bowser link Ness even we fit
trainer one after the other bang bang he
felt a strange sense of satisfaction
once he'd done his work great now the
character list only had the fair
balanced ones left they just so happened
to all be his favorite characters too
but why stop there Josh jumped across to
Elden ring and marched his Knight up
through the gate to Stormville Castle
before Margaret even had gotten through
his opening cut scene Josh had shot the
boss right in the face this boss battle
that he'd been stuck on for hours was
over before it even started what could
he do now he put on an episode of
stranger things and shot the demogorgon
then moth Gideon in the Mandalorian and
some goblins in Hogwarts Legacy the
clickers from The Last of Us took a
couple extra shots but went down easy
enough he went over to his PC and killed
the Ender Dragon in Minecraft without
blowing up any beds he won a game of
Rocket League 53-0 after he shot both
cars on the opposing team he played
through doors in Roblox without a single
jump scare he would just shoot any
monster that filled his screen what
could be better he reckoned it was time
for more movies walking back across the
lounge spinning the gun around his
finger like a western he wondered if now
would be a good chance to hunt down all
the legendary animals in Red Dead 2. it
would certainly make the job a lot
easier if he could kill them all in just
one shot he'd just need to be careful
not to shoot Arthur by accident but then
Josh sat on the remote the TV flicked
over to an old rerun of Bob Ross just
that he'd been squaring up to shoot he
pulled the trigger before he could react
the canvas was splattered red from
somewhere off camera he heard the
artist's wheezing voice try to comfort
him there are no mistakes just
happy but he died before he could say
another word the exposition gun first
came onto the SCP foundation's radar
when a strange police report was doing
the rounds on an email chain amongst
local authorities they were all finding
a great deal of value from a man called
Josh who had turned himself in at his
local station in Atlantic City for quote
killing like everyone naturally the
police took his report very seriously
for all of about 10 minutes as soon as
they realized he was talking about video
games TV and movie characters the whole
case turned into one big joke they sat
Josh down in front of a TV and played
him episodes of the shows he was talking
about pointing out characters still
alive in scenes after he'd supposedly
shot them to death but he seemed to just
grow more distressed as he realized he
was experiencing this phenomenon Alone
by the time Foundation agents tracked
Josh down and took him in for
questioning the gun had moved on he
marched it straight back to the old lady
who'd sold it to him whoever then sold
it on again Josh's full account of
events and description of the zapper
were taken before he was administered
Class C amnestics and allowed to
continue with his yard sale addiction
uninhibited
scp-674 was found sometime later in the
possession of a 33 year old Caucasian
male simply referred to as Mr S A
reclusive man in a neighboring City Mr s
first gained the SCP foundation's
attention through his extremist
political blog in which he claimed to
have assassinated prominent political
figures news anchors and talk show hosts
while the truth of those claims was
demonstrably false it was clear from the
way he described events that he really
did believe the delusion after being
questioned it was discovered that he had
never left his home instead he stayed on
his couch watching news reports and
firing at any prominent figures that
appeared believing that he was indeed
killing them in the real world despite
claiming that he was using scp-674 to
prevent a military police state using
the device to assassinate so many
high-profile figures had the opposite
effect on his video reality in his blog
posts he described an increasingly
unstable Global Order martial law and
catastrophic events consistent with the
hypothetical release of two deadly scps
his house was barricaded with security
cameras set up in every direction the
more he had been using the gun the more
of the characters and journalists saw on
TV had threatened him claiming that the
SCP Foundation were on their way to
apprehend him and that he would face
retribution for what he had been doing
Mr s's intended ambush of foundation
agents failed while they appeared to be
dying on these security feeds he had set
up the agents experienced no physical
harm in reality as they apprehended the
man and seized
scp-674 while the majority of
researchers have deemed that scp-674 is
harmless to all but the mental
well-being of the shooter there was a
notably Sinister result to miss Master
s's time and Foundation detention alone
in his cell Mr s soon started to engage
in heated arguments with the security
camera set up to monitor him there is no
record of any voices in the room other
than his own yet he seemed to be locked
in a fierce argument all of a sudden Mr
s dropped to the ground Dead with three
38 caliber handgun bullets lodged in his
chest the entirety of his holding cell
was searched for evidence of a shooter
but none was found the exposition gun
remains in a locked plastic case in
storage site 23 aside from regular
cleaning and maintenance it is used
under controlled circumstances to
creatively gather intelligence about
further SCP activity in the event of the
site being compromised Personnel are
allowed to destroy the exposition gun at
their own discretion should it fall into
the wrong hands
rock paper scissors a simple hand game
dating back to the Han Dynasty of
Imperial China it is a decisive game
between two players with the only
outcomes being Win Lose or Draw we're
quite familiar with rock paper scissors
here at the SCP Foundation as the guards
are often seen playing intense rounds of
the game to determine who will be the
Unlucky Soul chosen to secure one of the
various ketter class as CPS during a
given week in most cases this use of
rock paper scissors is accepted as a
largely harmless and Fair Way for
defensive Personnel to arrange their
chefs the reason for this is that the
results of rock paper scissors are
generally random as there are very few
ways for an individual's skill to
influence the game or someone might
think in reality rock paper scissors is
a deeply psychological game and this is
mainly because of its origin as a
contest between fellow human beings the
average human is vulnerable to making
errors and falling into patterns and
with only three options to keep track of
it is entirely possible for a seasoned
veteran of rock paper scissors to
predict their opponent's Choice before
any hands are thrown of course that
opponent may also commit an error of
their own by misreading the other
player's actions and thus there is
always a chance for an impulsive
decision to swing the results of the
game in either direction human
limitation is the only skill based
mechanic in the game of rock paper
scissors and that same limitation is
what in the eyes of some holds the game
back from reaching its true potential
that was the case until someone out
there discovered the rules to an
anomalous version of rock paper scissors
being spread through a mysterious email
while all attempts to trace the email
back to its original sender have left
the foundation with more questions than
answers we have been able to learn more
about the differences between the rules
of standard rock paper scissors and the
anomalous version we have given this
anomalous version of rock paper scissors
the designation
scp-4633 and unlike the classic edition
under no circumstances are any
foundation Personnel allowed to play a
game incorporating any of the
alternative rules while the ceiling for
skill and variety is theoretically much
higher in a rock paper scissors match
featuring
scp-4633 the risks to the player far
outweigh any added novelty here is how
scp-4633 functions during an average
game of rock paper scissors well average
prior to the anomalous properties taking
effect rather than being limited to
using merely rock paper or scissors as
the name of the game implies the players
gain access to a series of additional
hand gestures which upon the act of
being thrown becomes seamlessly
integrated into both players shared
understanding of the rules this alone
would be bizarre enough for the true
harm caused by scp-4633 is in the nature
of the gestures themselves when one of
the non-standard gestures Allowed by
scp-4633 is used the player's hands will
change shape in ways that under normal
circumstances would be anatomically
impossible each of these non-standard
gestures is distinct from the rest with
the only commonality being an unusual
tendency for the final gesture to
resemble biological structures often
seen in sea life one particular gesture
might cause a player to rapidly grow a
ring of additional fingers surrounding a
gaping anemone like mouth in the Palm
while another could result in the
player's entire arm flattening into a
fin-like appendage regardless of how
severe a departure from a typical human
limb the final gesture would be the
limbs and on rare occasions the entire
body of the player using the gesture
will quickly end irreversibly mutate
into the shape required to successfully
perform it while these gestures
overwhelmingly result in forms that
would be distressing to most people the
same cognitive effect that causes the
participants to accept changes to the
rules also appears to apply to the
changes affecting their own bodies to
the players of an scp-4633 augmented
match of rock paper scissors the
non-standard gestures seem as mundane as
the original Three unfortunately the
morphic properties of scp-4633 are
practically irreversible with extreme
reconstructive surgery being required in
even the best of cases in all instances
of
scp-4633 surgical intervention is
necessary to prevent the spread of
details regarding the non-standard
gestures and their usage because of the
immediate shift in cognitive awareness
among participants all that is needed
for a new instance of scp-4633 to occur
is the faintest hint of knowledge of the
alternative rules it's even been noted
that between different groups of players
the non-standard gestures can vary
heavily or seemingly be created on the
fly as the desire to win at all costs
takes hold here are a few examples of
anomalous gestures which have been
observed during instances of
scp-4633 this list is by no means
comprehensive but it will provide an
insight into how
scp-4633 drastically Alters the existing
mechanics of the game as well as the
physique of the players the thorily
gesture transforms the user's fingers
into Barbed tentacles it beats paper and
scissors but loses to rock chavoga folds
the fingers of the hand into the palm
and causes them to emerge through the
back of the Palm it allows the user to
throw a second gesture after they've
seen their opponent's Choice ashkelhas
splits the hand into a pair of poisonous
Stingers which also produce a potent
electrical current between them it has
been seen to lose to paper but seemingly
of their own will The Stingers lashed at
the opposing player and caused them to
fall unconscious three rounds later due
to the effects of the poison Chau sub
beats paper and two other anomal
gestures loses to scissors rock and a
third gesture and morphs the user's arm
into a Dactyl Club similar to the front
appendage of a mantis shrimp izorgov
Simply causes the player to grow three
additional thumbs on one hand the final
gesture resembles a triple thumbs up his
urugov has not been seen to beat any
gestures and the player who uses it
always seems to go on to lose the match
pagakumar causes the middle and ring to
recede into the hand while the pointer
and pinky fingers extend to resemble the
eye stalks of a snail or slug the rest
of the hand also becomes coated in a
thin layer of slime which continues to
secrete from within pagakmarg beats
scissors and paper but loses to Rock and
Another anomalous gesture known as
bayanjic incidentally Ryon Jack causes
the arm of the player using it to
elongate into a worm-like tube that
periodically spews a gout of salt water
on the opponent when vyanchek was seen
beating pagakmar the saltwater appeared
to have some adverse effect on the
ladder gesture causing the eye stocks to
droop and the hand to shrivel until it
was half its original size another
anomalous gesture is grazothrog
recognized by the skin muscle and veins
of the hand turning translucent
revealing a pulsing red organ in the
interior of the Palm once grisathrag has
been thrown the player who used it may
call out the name of one other gesture
which can no longer be used in the
current match the ukayak gesture is a
bit deceptive as it resembles Rock when
first thrown but gradually causes the
hand to condense into a lump of inert
material not dissimilar to actual
igneous rock the knuckles as well begin
to exude a superheated mineral substance
similar to molten lava ukayag
exclusively beats paper and appears to
lose to everything else many of the
gestures on record have no known name
but their function within
scp-4633's altered rules is clear from
the context in which they were used such
is the case with one anomalous gesture
which caused most of the player's hand
to withdraw into a siphon-like opening
at their wrist before the very same
orifice shot out a stream of ink into
the opposing player's eyes while there
was no lasting harm done to the opponent
by this gesture the ink did cause
temporary blindness which persisted
until they were defeated by way of their
Rock losing to paper another unknown
gesture has been seen beating both
izorogov and ukayag this gesture makes
the player's hand resemble the crest and
gas-filled body of a Pacific Mana War
these examples are only scraping the
surface of the seemingly Endless
Possibilities that scp-4633 has to offer
as you can see the anomalous hand
gestures can be just as dangerous within
the game itself as the permanent changes
they invoke in the user while the
foundation has done its best to contain
all information surrounding
scp-4633 there have been clear efforts
by several unknown groups to push the
game into continued usage over the past
three decades instances of scp-4633 have
seen increasing popularity in the world
of high-stakes gambling Perhaps it is
because of the inherent thrill of
watching two opponents trying to
strategically outwit each other with a
countless number of non-standard
gestures but more likely it is part of
the anomalous effect of
scp-4633 that the game would appeal to
those desperate to risk everything on
the slim chance of Victory this neatly
brings us to the scp-4633 related
incident which occurred aboard the
private ocean liner known as the SS
fateful Emma before the incident the
Fateful Emma would sail into
international waters twice a year each
time it would bring along a new group of
passengers seemingly selected from the
underprivileged and downcast sector of
society a great many of these passengers
were convicts with repeat violent
offenses chosen from supermax facilities
the world over the process by which
these inmates were chosen for a voyage
aboard the ship was not dissimilar from
the methods the Foundation uses to
acquire new class D Personnel naturally
this was how the research team was able
to be tipped off about the Fateful Emma
it became apparent soon after looking
into the ship's career that the
individuals altered by the effects of
scp-4633 had been seen departing from
the ship on multiple occasions in remote
island Harbors most of the time the
individuals would also be to the best of
their ability with their metamorphized
forms carrying briefcases filled with
hundreds of thousands of dollars in cash
while Witnesses tend to write off the
strange appearances of those affected as
being the result of a deformity or
injury or more pronounced instances
dismissing the encounters as sightings
of creatures from the local mythology it
was clear to anyone familiar with
scp-4633 what was truly going on these
passengers were being made to play
pitched games of rock paper scissors
featuring
scp-4633 for massive sums of wealth and
what was worse the grand prize win
owners were seemingly being released
back into civilization without the
knowledge of law enforcement of course
what the foundation was most concerned
about was the potential for the
large-scale leak of detailed information
involving
scp-4633 it seemed that the foundation's
latest faceless enemy had revealed
itself whatever wealthy group of
individuals was pulling the strings
behind the games aboard the SS fateful
Emma it was very likely that the ship
was also well protected by a private
Army of trained mercenaries in a display
of Swift but necessary initiative the
foundation assembled a brand new mobile
task force to be dispatched onto the
ocean liner mobile task force row 52
with the fitting code name Rochambeau
the mobile task force would board the
vessels secretly and use whatever means
necessary to prevent the spread of
scp-4633 and any evidence of the
associated non-standard hand gestures
before the Fateful Emma's next Voyage
the foundation isolated the port where
it would depart from and made sure that
the MTF agents were in position the
operation was co-captained by agent
DuBois and agent Shang both of whom
prided themselves on having
extraordinarily good luck agent Dubois
would stealthily move the majority of
the agents under his command into the
cargo hold below deck and await agent
Zhang's signal agent Zhang himself would
assume the name and identity of one of
the criminal passengers who was
intercepted before boarding by the
mobile task force the would-be
participant was subsequently detained
and brought into the foundation as a
Class D personnel as the SS fateful Emma
began to leave the harbor agent Zhang
joined the other passengers who had been
gathered together in an enormous
function hall there was little
indication of when the games would begin
and Zhang made an effort to keep a low
profile until more information was
available shortly after the ship had
officially arrived in international
waters an eccentric man entered the room
on a walkway that overlooked the rest of
the passengers he was flanked by pair of
armed bodyguards it was plain from the
man's style of dress and demeanor that
he was both absurdly wealthy and
completely out of his mind he wore a
pure white tuxedo and a scarf that
seemed to have been made from the fur of
a Siberian tiger a pair of Dark Shades
with sequined rims obscured his eyes
from view but by far the strangest
aspect of the rich man was the fact that
emerging from the wrist of his right arm
was the eyeless head of Amore eel where
his hand should be the man spoke
addressing the entire room welcome
passengers new and old to the SS fateful
Emma while you aboard this ship your
fate is in your own hands over the next
24 hours you will have the rare
opportunity to play the greatest game of
chance that Humanity has ever known
generations of people from every
continent and every Walk of Life have
given their all to the Mastery of rock
paper scissors across nosfox or slashes
the man proceeded to speak unusual
syllables for the next minute straight
without even a pause for breath in his
report agent Zhang described the man's
voice as gaining an increasingly loud
hum as his speech continued and that
some of the syllables didn't seem to be
the product of human vocal cords he soon
concluded his string of gibberish and
resumed speaking intelligible language
as is customary we will be utilizing the
iljesh toei rules you will Begin by
selecting a single opponent and
challenging them to a best of two of
three match this is a single elimination
tournament and any competitors who
cannot otherwise continue to engage in
matches will also be eliminated by the
end of your time here the luckiest among
you will be named the Undisputed
champion of these games and will be
granted unlimited Freedom along with the
cash prize the rest of you will have to
determine your own Fates where you all
know what a way to blow may your hands
be ready your minds be sharp and
remember winning is everything with a
flourish of his Moray EO ham the wealthy
man finished his introductions and
promptly exited the room ajin Zhang
looked at the passengers surrounding him
and saw that they were already beginning
to play Rock Paper Scissors with each
other a few had already begun using the
anomalous gestures warping their limbs
into hideous subnautical shapes agent
Zhang gave the signal to agent DuBois
and the rest of the mobile task force to
begin the operation their target was
primarily the Moray handed man as well
as any other Close Associates that he
had on board they would capture him
alive and interrogate him into revealing
the mystery behind this illegal gambling
ring once the mercenaries were dealt
with agent Dubois team would further
command the ocean liner and navigate it
to SCP Foundation research site-45 to
await further orders as for agent Zhang
he knew what he had to do to buy time he
would participate in the ensuing rock
paper scissors tournament and eliminate
as many of the other players as possible
people this he believed was the best way
to minimize the number of anomalous
gestures that would be used aboard the
ship of course he himself wouldn't be
using any of the anomalous gestures
either opting to limit himself to the
standard three this could put him at a
severe disadvantage over the course of
the competition but agent Zhang knew
better than to tempt fate still being
eliminated seemed like something he may
want to avoid even though the
consequences for elimination were left
vague in these strange rich man's speech
he still didn't feel that it would be
wise to put himself in a compromised
position while aboard the Fateful Emma
bracing himself for the worst agent
Chang accepted the challenge of a nearby
passenger he was off to a promising
start when he threw a scissors hand
against his opponent's paper because the
matches were best two out of three all
he needed was to win one of the next two
matches and he'd survive this round then
he saw the devious look on his
opponent's face and he knew that this
match was about to get weird rather than
admit feet agent Zhang prepared to throw
scissors again the two challenged their
hands and just as Zhang had feared his
opponent threw an anomalous gesture
almost instantly the opponent's hand
took on a multi-melt piscene form which
began to spit sharp teeth in agent
Zhang's Direction fortunately the
agent's bulletproof vest was able to
withstand the impact of the teeth what
was even more fortunate was the fact
that the opponent seemed to be a good
sport scissors beats azravak U.N said
the other passenger before walking away
in search of their next match curiously
the passengers transformed arm continued
to fire teeth across the room at random
intervals occasionally hitting and
causing injury to one of the other
competitors agent Zhang was grateful
that the body armor he was wearing had
been tested to withstand rapid fire from
scp-127 compared to the raw power of the
living gun the teeth launched from
asrovok gestures were practically BB
rounds he had succeeded in not being
eliminated both from the game and and
generally excited about his win Zhang
sought out another opponent to test his
lock below deck agent DuBois and the
rest of the mobile task force had just
finished facing off against some of the
hired mercenaries when they entered a
room presumed to be the ocean liners
sickbay inside was a grisly sight a
second rock paper scissors tournament
playing out between players that had
been so thoroughly transformed by the
anomalous gestures of
scp-4633 that they barely appeared to
still be human it was like a scene from
a deep sea documentary with strange and
unknowable creatures vying for dominance
not within a natural food chain or
competition for resources but within a
seemingly never-ending struggle to win a
game of chance it was Purgatory rock
paper scissors Purgatory agent DuBois
was appalled but he knew better than to
attempt to stop these creatures from
doing the one thing keeping them all
distracted the more a handed man was
still somewhere in the ship and
capturing him was far more important the
research team would decide what to do
with these former humans once the ship
was Secure within the foundation's
custody however what agent Dubois didn't
realize is that some of these creatures
were advancing on his team in
nightmarish and on Earthly voices they
chanted rock rock paper scissors
suddenly one of the Abominations
resembled nothing more closely than an
enormous mass of coral produce Four Arms
from within its body and began to throw
anomalous hand signs towards the agents
one of the arms threw akyag which coded
an unsuspecting agent in hot lava
causing him to drop to the floor in pain
Panic Dubois ordered the task force to
eliminate every living thing in the
sickbay although not in the sense of
their tournament standing of course
meanwhile ajin Zhang was on a win streak
in the function hall through sheer luck
and determination he had managed to
avoid elimination while eliminating
several other passengers himself he
began to notice that those who were
eliminated were quietly escorted way by
the bouncers seeming to have their
anomalous changes treated now it was
only down to 12 remaining passengers
agent Zhang knew that it was only a
matter of time before DuBois and his
team took control of the ship but
feeling Reckless he challenged one of
the remaining passengers in that moment
something came over him as if his
determination to see the mission through
was also compelling him to win at any
cost his opponent threw pagakmar and out
of instinct Zhang through vignan Jack
the agent went on to win the entire
tournament but sadly he was unable to
collect the prize money as during the
Skirmish below deck the man with the
Moray hand had escaped with a small
fortune in a high-speed submersible his
ultimate goals and the scope of the
shadowy group he represented would
remain unanswered for the time being
when the SS fateful Emma finally arrived
at site-45 agent Zhang came to his
senses and realized that he had
underestimated the cognitive side
effects of
scp-4633 due to the immediately
recognizable anomalous state of both his
arms agent Zhang was later contained on
site with minimal security it's believed
that researchers are still searching for
a method to reverse the effects it just
goes to show that winning isn't
everything the thin pale humanoid
anomaly had just found itself in
Minecraft of all places the all too
familiar whale of emergency alarms rang
out through the corridors of the
foundation facility it had happened
again another containment breach of
course the on-site Personnel were more
than familiar with the protocols for a
situation like this so well-versed in
what to do during an emergency that it
had become second nature whether they
were research staff evacuating for their
own safety or security teams moving in
to recapture the escaped anomaly and get
the situation under control everyone was
moving like they had been programmed
muscle memory taking over the loose
anomaly was none other than
scp-096 all Foundation Personnel were
alerted and reminded not to look
directly at the creature there was just
one problem they couldn't look even if
they'd ignored their order to try nobody
could because the shy guy was nowhere to
be found well nowhere in the real world
at least this whole situation bizarre
even by Foundation standards had all
started with an experiment involving a
member of the Disposable d-class
Personnel yet another dangerous convict
serving one of several life sentences
now being used as an Expendable human
lab rat for the foundation's often
Sinister purposes the experiment in
question was an attempt to further test
the limitation of
scp-096's abilities by now the
foundation had done extensive research
into the creature known as the shy guy
they knew its particular brand of
anomalous qualities were triggered when
anyone looked directly at it being
observed would instantaneously send
scp-096 into an uncontrollable rage
state causing it to pursue its Observer
until they were no longer standing
scp-096 was known to be able to travel
at speeds so relentless it was pretty
much impossible to stop one moment it
was sobbing and screeching in its cell
having just been observed and minutes
later the wide jawed long-limmed monster
was standing behind whoever had seen it
making its screaming face the image its
victim took to the Grave with them
Foundation researchers knew that
scp-096's rage State could be triggered
by as little as someone seeing the
slightest hint of a creature even if the
shy guy had been captured as a tiny
Speck in the background of a photograph
it would come after anyone whose eyes so
much as glanced over that Speck it also
didn't matter how far away the Observer
was
scp-096 could not be outrun it could
track down anyone wherever they were in
the world but what if a person who had
observed the shy guy was no longer in
the world the experiment had taken a lot
of trial and error after all digitizing
a human being and transforming their
entire Consciousness into code was no
easy task but the foundation was an
above breaking more than a few eggs to
make an omelet especially when those
eggs were the brains of a few d-class
Personnel actually the first test
subjects turned out more scrambled or
fried certainly overdone given the
amount of smoke coming from their ears
but eventually the research team had
perfected the device they dubbed the
neural harness a headset that could
translate a person's mind into pure
digital code their Consciousness would
be extracted from their body leaving
their physical form an empty shell while
a digital copy of them was able to
Traverse the local on-site computer
network of course the foundation wasn't
about to let a digitized d-class run
amok with their systems so their coding
experts wrote a number of specialized
parameters into their successful test
subject now the digital d-class could be
programmed to follow the foundation's
directive from his perspective it was
like he was floating through cyberspace
towards the system that the foundation
had directed him to a surveillance
camera inside
scp-096's cell that usually remained
inactive but not today the camera
blinked to life as soon as the d-class's
code-based Consciousness reached it and
through it it was able to observe as
cp096 sitting against the far wall of
its containment chamber gently
whimpering and walking back and forth
that is until the creature felt that
same familiar sensation of being watched
it stood up enraged wailing
uncontrollably as the d-class watched
from within the camera then a split
second later
scp-096 appeared to Blink out of
existence it hadn't worked the
experiment had failed and the digital
d-class began to panic before the
foundation coders could stop him he
frantically scoured the local network
for anything some kind of Escape Route
back into the real world maybe he
thought if he could get back into his
body it wouldn't count account
technically his digital self was
separate from his physical form so he
might get out of scp-096's clutches on a
technicality but it was impossible his
body was already burned out by the
neural harness there was no way for the
d-class to transfer himself back there
was only one option left hide and as it
turned out someone had forgotten to
uninstall a certain building game from a
computer in one of the foundation
doctor's offices the d-classes digitized
mind zapped him into Minecraft from his
point of view it was like he existed
within the game itself he did a
computerized equivalent of breathing a
sigh of relief only to take back all
those ones and zeroes in a horrified
gasp as he noticed a tall wiry frame
figure before him it hadn't worked
scp-096 had still managed to follow him
into Minecraft even in a world of
computer code the shy guy was able to
dispatch its digital Observer quite
easily in what had once been a living
human mind in the form of binary code
was quickly deleted but that's when
scp-096 started to take notice of its
surroundings but the most recent person
to see it gone it had the chance to
actually take in where it was the bright
rays of warm light coming down from a
cube-shaped sun reveal a welcoming
landscape all around constructed
entirely from cubes it fascinated
scp-096 instilling a kind of childlike
Wonder in the shy guy the likes of which
it hadn't experience since well since it
couldn't remember when rather than
leaving instantly reappearing in its
containment chamber
scp-096 made the conscious decision to
start exploring there was a mountainous
biome surrounding scp-096 Stony spiers
reaching up towards a clear sky with a
waterfall cascading its way down the
nearest of them at the foot of the
mountains was the opening of a cave
which the shy guy found itself wandering
towards the light from the sun while a
pleasant and welcoming change to the
surrounding it was used to was a little
harsh on scp-096's sunken eyes so
instead it began to gravitate towards
the shadowy confines of the caves not
unlike the usual darkness of its
containment chamber back at the
foundation traversing through long
winding corridors of stone as cp096
found itself having to bend down to
avoid hitting its head on the Cave's low
ceiling obviously this formation of
Rocky blocks had informed with someone
of the shy guy's height in mind there
was a low Warm Glow coming from the
farthest side of the tunnel and the thin
creature made its way closer and closer
despite the stone walls around it
feeling like a tighter confinement than
its cell approaching the source of the
light
scp-096 was relieved that the cave
opened out into a more spacious area the
grand tunnel giving way to an expansive
chamber that lay within the heart of the
mountain the warm orangey glow that had
been coming from a flowing stream of
boiling hot lava that seemed to trickle
down from somewhere above creating a
deadly fiery pool directly in the Shy
Guy's path but just before it could turn
back and leave the cave through the way
he came
scp-096 sensed that familiar feeling of
something observing him across the lava
pool on the other side was a creature
comprised of a green Cube for a head
with a long armless cuboid body and four
cubed feet if it had been present in the
real world it might have been made out
of leaves like a living shrub it was
staring directly at the shy guy from
across the lava only for the strange
newcomer to disappear a moment later the
creeper hissed before it realized that
scp-096 had leaped up behind it to land
a fatal blow but little did the
infamously anxious anomaly realized that
the sentient shrub wasn't done there was
a colossal boom that caused scp-096 to
stagger backwards whimpering at the
sudden loud explosion and the pain that
I've accompanied it the creeper had
blown itself to Pieces but in doing so
had left a lasting injury that caused
scp-096 considerable discomfort as it
began limping towards the cave that led
out the opposite side of the mountain
despite its injury the shy guy was still
able to move with relative ease and the
further it went the more it seemed to
gradually heal however it was as it
stepped out once more into the sunlight
that the creature realized just how
hungry it was back in the real world it
hadn't eaten for several hours and
surprisingly even while accidentally
stuck in digitized form the hunger
mechanics of Minecraft were having an
effect on
scp-096 the shy guy started searching
around for anything that could prove to
satiate its hunger there was a Grove of
trees not far so scp-096 lumbered to
take a closer look it couldn't be
certain but it felt there was at least a
slim chance that there were apples
growing amongst the leaves but even at
the anomaly's own elongated height it
couldn't simply reach up to pick them
however it was while swiping its arms up
at the tree that the shy guy swung its
Fist and knocked at the tree trunk to
the creature's surprise who was able to
chip away at the wood with its hands
punching at the tree until the trunk had
been reduced to a collection of wooden
blocks the shy guy was able to collect
and sure enough some red apples dropped
from the leaves above enough to quell
the hunger that scp-096 was feeling at
least for the time being nearby
something was moving through the trees
it was yet to lock eyes on scp-096 but
the second it did the mob would surely
have sealed its own fate as it moved
around minding its own business the tall
figure overheard the sounds of the shy
guy eating and its attention was drawn
to where the creature was standing
enjoying an apple sensing that it had
been seen as cp096 turned and locked
eyes with the entity it was perhaps the
only other being in Minecraft that was a
similar height and stature to the
anomaly itself in fact the pair were
strikingly similar before scp-096 could
carry out its usual method of attack the
Enderman suddenly teleported out of view
but it was too late now both it and the
shy guy had looked at the other's face
both had been provoked and were
compelled to react in exactly the same
way just as scp-096 entered its rage
State the Enderman 2 opened its mouth
and began to shake making loud lengthy
sounds not dissimilar to the Shy Guy's
own angered screams but something
profoundly strange happened next
scp-096 and the Enderman kept attempting
to pursue one another appearing in a new
location within the Minecraft world
neither one getting close enough to the
other they'd teleport only for the other
to teleport away the moment they saw
each other each trying to catch one
another but only staying one step behind
this rapid Chase almost became a strange
ongoing sort of teleporting dance
between
scp-096 and the Enderman at first the
shy guy had been compelled to attack the
Enderman like it was with any who looked
directly at it but as they appeared and
disappeared from place to place the
creature started to feel an odd kinship
with this shadowy fellow it was so used
to being frightened and alone to its
overwhelming feelings of insecurity and
self-loathing that the Simplicity of
just traversing the open world for the
creature very alike itself in many ways
it had all come as a welcome change
scp-096 found it therapeutic even and
before long was following the Enderman
not out of any intention to do it harm
but just to feel for a little while like
it had a friend just a little bit longer
as cp096 thought welcoming the enjoyment
it felt playing this game of Minecraft
now go check out scp-1471 Mal o but
hacked Minecraft and SCP Minecraft world
Destroyer as cp-4335 a welt in The
Crucible for more